Hey guys, my name's Sean. I like long walks on the beach. I'm a cancer. I like sweets, cake, cookies, ice cream. I have a littlearks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks.
大家好，我叫肖恩。我喜欢在海滩上长距离散步。我是巨蟹座。我喜欢甜食、蛋糕、曲奇、冰淇淋。我有小小的... Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。
Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Will, when we were chatting yesterday, you were on your walk. Yeah. And Jason, I know, I have no if you've ever called Will on his walk, but it's all uphill. Yeah. And it's... So, what's going on? What are you doing tonight?
Smarks。Smarks。Smarks。威尔，我们昨天聊天的时候，你正在散步。对。杰森，我知道，我不知道你有没有给正在散步的威尔打过电话，但那全是上坡路。没错。而且是……那么，最近怎么样？你今晚要做什么？
That whole time. I'm sorry. And I was like, just calm it when you're done. No, but it's a great way what ends up happening is, it's a great way for me to stay out of my head because it is a tough walk. And then all of a sudden, I'm like, I don't want to let him halfway down.
在那期间。对不起。我就想，结束时冷静点。不，但这真是一个好方法，最后发生的是，这是一个让我不再胡思乱想的好方法，因为这是一段艰难的散步。然后突然间，我就想，我不想让他在半山腰失望。
What do you guys talk about? What was, what's on the phone yesterday? Yeah. What we were doing, I was doing that night. We were talking about what he's doing that night, and about, I was asking him if he was going on that trip that everybody's going on next week to see that thing in that place. All right. You mean tomorrow?
你们在聊什么？昨天电话里聊了什么？对。我们在聊什么，我那天晚上在做什么。我们当时在聊他那天晚上要做什么，关于，我问他是不是要去参加下周所有人都去的那场旅行，去那个地方看那个东西。好吧。你是说明天？
No, is it tomorrow? Oh, it's Friday. Yeah, sorry, tomorrow, that you guys are all doing. You can say what it is, why not? Yeah, it's Friday. Yeah, sorry. Tomorrow that you guys are all doing. You can say what it is. Why not? Yeah, it's the GoCe YouTube and the new sphere thing. And you guys are all going. Sean's not. Are you Sean? Not going. J.B. Sean's not going.
不，是明天吗？哦，是星期五。对，抱歉，是明天，你们所有人都要去的活动。你可以说出来是什么，为什么不呢？对，是星期五。对，抱歉。明天你们所有人都要去的活动。你可以说出来是什么。为什么不呢？对，就是GoCe YouTube和那个新球体场馆的活动。你们所有人都要去。肖恩不去。对吧，肖恩？不去。J.B. 肖恩不去。
And then I was like feeling guilt about it a little bit because I don't know. And... Well, you just got back from London, you know? You just got back. You got a bunch more sleeves to cut off your Liverpool t-shirts. You're going to be busy this weekend. This is an old t-shirt, is it?
然后我为此感到有点内疚，因为我不知道。还有……嗯，你刚从伦敦回来，你知道的。你刚回来。你还有一堆利物浦T恤的袖子要剪掉。你这周末有得忙了。这是一件旧T恤，对吧？
Yeah. Oh, it is. Does Justin know that it's missing yet? Or I only do it when I'm doing when I'm on like my walk or working out. Do what? Cut sleeves. Wear a sleeveless. Yeah, just because I get so hot.
对。哦，是的。贾斯汀知道它少了一截吗？或者我只有在散步或锻炼的时候才这么做。做什么？剪袖子。穿无袖的。对，因为我太热了。
Yeah, yeah. Oh, the sun is so amazed by how much you're physically on your biceps. Yeah, just because I get so hot. Yeah, yeah. Well, you know, all of a sudden, you're so amazed by how much, basically, on your biceps. Yeah, it gets hot guns. Hot guns. Hot. Hot. I'm going to make a t-shirt for both of those hot guns. I knew guns. I knew what. Can I just tell you something? I was about to, I was walking down the stairs, come down to set up through this record. And all of a sudden, it goes, send it goes, what are you doing?
对，对。哦，太阳对你的二头肌的锻炼程度感到非常惊讶。对，因为我太热了。对，对。嗯，你知道，突然之间，你对基本上你的二头肌的锻炼程度感到非常惊讶。是的，变得很热。很热的肌肉。热。热。我要为这两块热辣的肌肉做一件T恤。我认识的肌肉。我知道什么。我能告诉你一件事吗？我当时正准备，我正走下楼梯，下来为这次录音做准备。然后突然间，她说，发出了声音，说，你在干什么？
And I go, well, I'm going from my walk. She goes, but are you doing smartness? I go, yeah. And then she goes, and I was like, fuck, yeah, you're right. I might take some heat. But then I was like, I'm already, I'm already committed. So fuck it. And I'm good for the opening.
我说，嗯，我要去散步。她说，但你是在做smartness吗？我说，对。然后她说，然后我就想，操，对，你说得对。我可能会承受一些压力。但接着我想，我已经，我已经决定了。所以管他呢。而且我开场状态很好。
I'm getting bigger. Vegas. Oh, see, you would be great at Vegas. Can I wear this to Vegas, do you think? I'm very excited to see the whole sphere. I know it's going to be cool. I wasn't asked to go, but I would love to go. Well, you've got six weeks. They're doing a six-week residence. Oh, sure. Yeah, I'll go.
我越来越壮了。拉斯维加斯。哦，看，你在拉斯维加斯一定会很棒。你觉得我可以穿这个去拉斯维加斯吗？我很兴奋能看到整个球体场馆。我知道这会很酷。没有人邀请我去，但我很想去。好吧，你还有六周时间。他们要做一个为期六周的驻场演出。哦，当然。好吧，我会去的。
Sean, maybe you and me and Scott and I will go. We'll go for like, we'll zip in and out. Yeah, fine. Just the day. Just the day. Well, we have to go. It's that night. Oh, well, we'll come back tonight.
肖恩，也许你、我和斯科特一起去。我们会去，比如，我们会快去快回。好吧，行。就一天。就一天。嗯，我们得去。就是那天晚上。哦，好吧，我们今晚就回来。
I know you two are doing mat nays. Do I go one of you guys like like do you guys? Do you guys like the tables? Are you gamblers? I love it. I live for it. Really? I like Sean likes the gamble. What's your game? Rulette and Blackjack. His game is losing money. Do you remember JB when we did the card game with Coli gas and those guys back in the day and Jack black and those guys and The first time Sean came to the game. We we've been doing it for like a month or two and then Sean comes Just was like I said going I'm all in I'm all in and this is like 20 years ago And he won like $1,500 and then it's like, oh my God, it goes, oh my God, it's late. I got to go and everybody's like, you're not fucking going.
我知道你们两个要在日场演出。我不知道你们两个喜欢吗，比如你们喜欢赌桌吗？你们是赌徒吗？我太喜欢了。我为它而活。真的吗？我喜欢肖恩喜欢赌博。你玩什么？轮盘和二十一点。他的游戏是输钱。你还记得JB吗，我们以前和科利加斯那些家伙，还有杰克·布莱克那些家伙一起玩纸牌游戏的时候。那是肖恩第一次来参加这个游戏。我们已经玩了一个月左右，然后肖恩来了，就像，我当时说，我全押了，我全押了。这大概是20多年前的事了，他赢了大约1500美元，然后就像，哦天哪，他说，哦天哪，时间不早了，我得走了。每个人都说，你他妈的休想走。
Do you have to win and then walk? I never came back. I know. He tried. Roulette, boy, that's um, I like roulette too. Do you? It's kind of, I thought only people like take cruises, uh, play roulette. Who? Perhaps it's, it perhaps is great. People that take cruises play roulettelette. Who? Perhaps it's great. People that take cruises, play roulette and slot machines, right?
你必须赢了就走吗？我再也没回来过。我知道。他试过了。轮盘，天哪，那是……我也喜欢轮盘。是吗？这有点，我以为只有那些去坐游轮的人才玩轮盘。谁？也许这很棒。那些坐游轮的人玩轮盘赌和老虎机，对吧？
I hate losing money though. I don't really like to gamble that much. Because the roulette, yeah, I love it. I tell you what's not a gamble. Uh-oh, nice, nice segue. Nice segue. I'll just hear you say it again. I tell you what's not a gamble is our guest today.
不过我讨厌输钱。我其实不是很喜欢赌博。因为轮盘，对，我喜欢。我告诉你什么不是赌博。哦，太棒了，漂亮的衔接。漂亮的衔接。我真想听你再说一遍。我告诉你什么不是赌博，那就是我们今天的嘉宾。
I am profoundly excited about our guest. I have been a massive, massive fan of this person's work for a long, long, long time. In fact, almost as long as I can remember, not quite, but almost as. This is a, this is the true artist, in my view. Somebody who is, I think, not only created so much incredible music over the years, but also has inspired so much incredible music. And I know that from reading from what other people say about him. And what he has done, you know, people sort of try to at first were saying that they were
我对我们的嘉宾感到无比的兴奋。长期以来，我一直是这个人作品的超级超级粉丝。事实上，几乎从我有记忆以来就开始了，虽然不完全是，但也差不多了。依我来看，这是一位真正的艺术家。不仅在这些年里创作了如此多令人难以置信的音乐，而且还启发了如此多令人难以置信的音乐。我知道这一点，从阅读别人对他的评价中就能看出来。他所做的一切，你知道的，人们一开始试图说他们
the first kind of really great American post-punk band. I like to think that they are the first really great and probably without embarrassing them, really first great sort of indie band in a way. This is somebody who is just in his own right, a great artist, a visual artist, a photographer, a filmmaker, but also an incredible songwriter, singer, band member, just all around great American icon. You guys, it's none other than REM's Michael Steip. No, my God. I was just thinking about him the other day.
是第一支真正伟大的美国后朋克乐队。我倾向于认为他们是第一支真正伟大，而且可能在不让他们难堪的前提下，可以说是第一支真正伟大的某种意义上的独立乐队。这是一位凭实力本身就很伟大的艺术家，一位视觉艺术家、摄影师、电影制作人，同时也是一位出色的词曲作者、歌手、乐队成员，总而言之是一个伟大的美国偶像。各位，他不是别人，正是R.E.M.乐队的迈克尔·斯泰普。哦，天哪。我刚才还在想他呢。
No way. Michael, reveal yourself. There he is. Hey, guys. Oh, my God. Michael Steip. So weird. I was just thinking, I think yesterday of the day before, like, we gotta try to get Michael Steip on this show. No shit. I swear to God.
绝不可能。迈克尔，现身吧。他就在那儿。大家好。哦，天哪。迈克尔·斯泰普。太奇怪了。我刚才还在想，大概昨天或前天吧，我们就得设法把迈克尔·斯泰普请到这个节目来。真的假的？我向上帝发誓。
Oh my God. I'm a huge fan. Wow. Good morning. Well right back, I'm a huge fan of each of you guys as well. So I'm really happy to be here. So great to meet you. Well, thank you, Fred. I know.
哦，天哪。我是你的超级粉丝。哇。早上好。同样同样，我也是你们每个人的超级粉丝。所以我很高兴来到这里。很高兴见到你们。谢谢你，弗雷德。我知道。
Good one. I know. Real good one. I've been, I've been, I often listen to a lot of your music, Michael, from over the years. And of course, in the last few days and anticipation of meeting you, I've been listening to a lot and really introducing my teenage sons to sit like this morning waiting for the bus, in fact.
说得好。我知道。真的说得很好。迈克尔，这些年来我经常听你的很多音乐。当然，在过去的几天里，为了迎接你的到来，我听了很多，事实上，今天早上在等校车的时候，我真的向我十几岁的儿子们大力推荐了这些音乐。
And we were listening to, we were listening to fall. You should buy a car, Will. I know, it's not high. It is true, but I like the bus. Okay. And I just, you know, it, I started going down memory lane for you, and I can't imagine what that's like for you as people start to talk to you about the sort of,
我们当时在听，我们当时在听fall。威尔，你应该买辆车。我知道，这不高。确实如此，但我喜欢坐公交车。好吧。我只是觉得，它，我开始为你回顾过往，我无法想象当人们开始跟你谈论那种
you know, the entire catalog of music that you've created over the years. Do you, and I've asked people this before, do you feel, I don't know, do you feel the weight of this breadth of work that you've created? Is that something that occurs to you? Do you understand it? Can you appreciate it without, you know, as much as you're comfortable talking about
你知道的，你这些年创作的全部音乐目录时，对你来说那是什么感觉。你，我以前也问过别人这个感觉，你是否，我不知道，你是否感受到了你所创作的如此浩瀚的作品的分量？这是你会偶尔想到的事情吗？你能理解它吗？在你在谈论这种事情感到舒适的范围内，你能欣赏它吗？
that kind of thing? Yeah, I mean, I always love it when people walk up to me and say, you know, this or that song really meant something to me at this point in my life. And thank you for being there. And, you know,, it's all it's really always about the music. And but I feel like it's my job, you know, moving forward in time to to be graceful about that when it when it happens. Sometimes people also just don't like me. And that's okay to. I don't know anybody. We get we have.
是的，我的意思是，每当有人走到我面前说，你知道，这首歌或那首歌在我的这段人生中真的很有意义，谢谢你曾陪伴左右，我总是很高兴。而且，你知道，这一切其实都归结于音乐。但我觉得我的职责是，你知道，随着时间推移，当这种情况发生时，要优雅地对待它。有时人们也会单纯地不喜欢我。这也没关系。我不知道任何人。我们有。
I live in New York. So I get you know, it's not like LA. It's like you people tell you what they think and sometimes they yell it from across the street. But, and so you get that too. But let's start at the top. I like the sleeveless look, Will, thank you for having me on. I got the memo, so I were read, but I didn't take the sleeves off, so I'm sorry for that. It's not too late. Yeah, it's not too late.
我住在纽约。所以我知道，这不像洛杉矶。人们会告诉你他们的想法，有时他们会隔着街对你大喊。所以你也会遇到这种情况。但我们从头开始吧。我喜欢无袖的造型，威尔，谢谢你邀请我来。我收到便条了，所以我穿了红色，但我没有把袖子剪掉，所以对此我很抱歉。现在还不算晚。对，现在还不算晚。
And I'll see you guys in Las Vegas because I got an invitation to come. Oh, that's great. Are you going? Oh, I can't wait. Well, I have to figure out exactly when. So maybe we can, maybe we can, you guys can coordinate that after we're picking up. I'll pick you up and that wills bus.
我会在拉斯维加斯见到你们的，因为我收到了邀请。哦，太棒了。你要去吗？哦，我等不及了。嗯，我得弄清楚具体是什么时候。所以也许我们可以，也许我们可以，等我们录完后你们可以协调一下。我会用威尔的公交车载你。
We'll. I am coming to, I'm coming to the West Coast soon, which is, I'm kind of allergic to Los Angeles. So it's going to be, you know, we can hold your hand at a nice dinner. Yeah, come and have dinner with us, man. I'm a transplant. I lived in New York for over 20 years. I've really only been here full time
我们。我很快要去西海岸了，其实我对洛杉矶有点过敏。所以这将会是，你知道的，我们可以在一顿不错的晚餐上拉着你的手。对，来和我们一起吃晚饭吧，伙计。我是个外地搬来的人。我在纽约住了20多年。我真正全职住在这里
for 10 years, I guess, almost. So I get it. And it is, it's always an adjustment. I spent years like living in New York and then working out here. Remember, JB, when we were doing our thing and I was like every weekend, I would go home. Yeah.
大概有10年了吧，差不多。所以我懂。而且这确实总需要一个适应的过程。我花了几年时间在纽约生活，然后在这边工作。JB，还记得我们在搞那个的时候，我几乎每个周末都要回家。是的。
I gotta get back to New York. Oh, so I get- When we were doing our thing, isn't that sweet? You can't, but Willie, you couldn't imagine living in New York full-time again right now, could you? You know, I don't know. I ended up, I don't know if I say falling in love with L.A. But I ended up being like, okay, and once I had kids,
我得回纽约去。哦，所以我懂——当我们做我们的事情时，多甜美啊。你不能，但是威利，你现在无法想象重新全职住在纽约了吧，对吗？你知道，我不知道。我最后发现，我不知道我算不算是爱上了洛杉矶。但我最终觉得，好吧，一旦我有了孩子，
it kind of changed my perspective. But then, I spent a fair bit of time back there, especially in the summer. And I don't know, I could. Michael, could you ever imagine living out in L.A. full time? I did live there for a couple of years in the early 90s. That was really fun. And then the earthquake came, and my face got condemned and flattened.
这在某种程度上改变了我的看法。但后来，我在那边呆了相当长一段时间，特别是在夏天。我不知道，我确实可以。迈克尔，你能想象全职住在洛杉矶吗？我在90年代初在那儿住过几年。那真的很有趣。然后地震来了，我的房子被判定为危房并被夷为平地。
No way and so I moved into Hollywood and I lived actually, I lived out of the Shatom Vermont for a couple of years as my second home. Second different earthquake. Yeah, that's a different all-together situation. But it was really fun and it was really like it was still really shabby and cool and reality TV hadn't happened yet. So things were a little more tolerable. Michael pardon my ignorance.
真的吗？所以我搬到了好莱坞，事实上我在沙托佛蒙特住了几年，作为我的第二个家。第二次不同的地震。对，那是完全不同的情况。但它真的很有趣，而且它依然非常破旧和酷，真人秀当时还没出现。所以事情更容易忍受一些。迈克尔，请原谅我的无知。
I know nothing. I live in a hole. I'm under a rock. I was a singer in a band called R.I.M. for 32. That's how people most know me as to my voice. Yes. I've also worked on other things. But with the well-deserved compliments
我什么都不知道。我住在洞里。我躲在岩石底下。我曾是一支名为R.I.M.的乐队的主唱，持续了32年。人们主要通过我的声音认识我。是的。我也参与过其他事情。但随着威尔给你的那些实至名归的赞美，
that Will was giving you, so in reference to that incredible body of work and creativity and forward thinking and pushing, teaching us all had to enjoy stuff that's a little bit more challenging. Where are you pointing that today? What are you excited about pointing that incredible talent at today? My own work? Yeah.
呼应那个令人难以置信的作品集、创造力、前瞻性思维和推动力，教会我们所有人都去欣赏那些更具挑战性的东西。你今天把这些指向了哪里？今天，你对把这种令人难以置信的天赋聚焦于何处感到兴奋？我自己的作品？对。
Well, it's multi-directional. Right now, as we sit here talking, I'm putting together a show of artwork that's going to debut in December and Milan at the ICA Milan, which is for me really super exciting because it's the first institution show that I've ever done, and the largest show I've done in Europe. So that's super exciting. It's a painter. No, good Lord.
嗯，它是多方向的。此时此刻，当我们坐在这里交谈时，我正在筹备一场艺术作品展，将于12月在米兰的米兰ICA首展，对我来说这真的超级令人兴奋，因为这是我做过的第一个机构展览，也是我在欧洲做过的最大展览。所以这超级令人兴奋。是个画家。不，天哪。
I'm the worst painter on Earth. I mean, really, really bad. I established that when I was 20 years old in art school at the University of Georgia. I tried philosophy that was really, I'm interesting to me, I couldn't wrap my head around those kind of concepts. I tried English lit, I loved it,
我是地球上最糟糕的画家。我是说，真的，真的非常糟糕。我在佐治亚大学读艺术学校时20岁就确立了这一点。我尝试过哲学，那真的，对我有吸引力，但我无法理解那种概念。我尝试过英国文学，我非常喜欢，
but I was really a terrible student. And so then I finally wound up at the art school, which is where I belonged, because that's where all the really cool kids were. And that's where you got laid. And that's where you sat around and drank espresso and figured out what the world should look like instead of what it did look like in the team. And, um, yeah, so no, I'm a terrible painter.
但我真的是个糟糕的学生。所以最后我终于去了艺术学校，那才是属于我的地方，因为那里都是真正酷的孩子。那是你泡到妞的地方。那是你坐在一起喝意式浓缩咖啡，琢磨世界应该是什么样子，而不是它在10年代实际样子的对方。然后，是的，所以不，我是个糟糕的画家。
I'm a terrible painter. Yes, sculpture, it's sculpture pieces. I'm working in concrete and plastic and plaster. Oh, wow. And then, um, and then a lot of photographs because I take a ton of pictures and I kind of, I've never kept a journal or a diary, but I have consistently taken photographs my entire life to kind of remember, like, wow, I met that guy there or we had that launcher dinner. And this is when I visited Lithuania
我是个糟糕的画家。是的，雕塑，那是雕塑作品。我用混凝土、塑料和石膏创作。哦，哇。然后，嗯，还有大量的照片，因为我拍了大量的照片，我有点，我从来没有写过日记或日志，但我一生中一直在持续拍照，以此来记住，比如，哇，我在那儿遇到了那个人，或者我们吃了那顿午餐或晚餐。这是我访问立陶宛的时候，
and that's what it looks like. And I love brutalism and whatever it goes on and on. But that's funny you say that you never come to diary and yet you did in a sense that you pointed out you have this sort of years of photographs that you've taken over time that kind of document you're moving through the world. And also, you have all these great songs that are also representative. I think, probably, again, I don't want to put words in your mouth, representative of where you're at at various points in your life and how you viewed
它看起来就是那个样子。我喜欢粗野主义，诸如此类，没完没了。但有趣的是你这么说，你从不写日记，然而在某种意义上你确实写了，正如你所指出的，你拥有这些年来拍摄的大量照片，它们记录了你穿梭于世界的过程。而且，你还有所有这些伟大的歌曲，它们也具有代表性。我想，可能吧，再次声明，我不想替你说话，它们代表了你在人生不同阶段的立场，以及你如何看待
things potentially. Yeah, I mean, it's certainly details of my political activism and my kind of coming out of, like, you know, a kind of political, like, activist dark place into, like, seeing the light and seeing, like, who we were as Americans to the rest of the world and then trying to respond to that or react to that. But I've never been an autobiographic writer. I mean, I had this conversation with all people,
潜在的事物。是的，我的意思是，这当然是我政治激进主义的细节，以及我从某种政治激进的黑暗之地走出来，看到光明，看到我们作为美国人对世界其他地方而言是谁，然后试图对此做出回应或反应。但我从来都不是一个自传式的作家。我的意思是，我和所有人有过这样的对话，
recently, Patty Smith, and we're talking about writers who are essentially autobiographic writers, and then those who are not. And I tend to fictionalize like everything that goes into the words that I write for songs. So as a lyricist, there's maybe like, I'm not kidding, like eight songs in the whole canon of REM and other stuff that I've done outside of that, that actually are very, very, very personal to me. The rest of it is a lot of imagination. Oh, wow. And Patty Smith was a, if I'm right, not mistaken, was a big influence on you early on, even
最近是帕蒂·史密斯，我们在谈论那些基本上是自传式作家的作家，以及那些不是的作家。我倾向于把写进歌曲歌词里的所有东西都虚构化。所以作为一个作词人，也许有，我不是在开玩笑，在R.E.M.的整个作品目录以及我在此之外所做其他事情中，只有大约八首歌对我来说实际上是非常、非常、非常私人的。其余的大部分都是想象。哦，哇。如果我没记错的话，帕蒂·史密斯在早期对你产生了很大的影响，甚至
before you started REM. Is that right? Like, you were just like really obsessed with her and would just, and I don't know if obsessed is the right thing. But. No, obsessed is not a bad word. I mean, I just, I bought and listened to horses the day it came out. I was 15 years old. And I decided then and there that that's what I was going to do.
在你开始R.E.M.之前。是这样吗？就像你当时对她非常着迷，并且，我不知道“着迷”是不是合适的词。但是。不，着迷不是个坏词。我的意思是，我买下了《Horses》并在它发行的那一天就听了。我当时15岁。我当即决定那就是我要做的事情。
And it was, you know, I was 15. It was really a naive choice. But I, you know, it manifested four years later. I was still a teenager when I started Aureum. And we went on from there. I was still a teenager when I started R.E.M. and we went on from there. I was insanely ambitious. And I knew what I didn't want to do, which was hold down a regular job.
而且，你知道，我当时15岁。这确实是一个天真的选择。但我，你知道，它在四年后成为了现实。当我组建R.E.M.时我还只是个十几岁的青少年，我们从那里开始发展。当我组建R.E.M.时我还只是个十几岁的青少年，我们从那里开始发展。我有着疯狂的野心。我知道我不想做什么，那就是找一份常规的工作。
Right. And are you, we get that. But yeah, sorry, can I just say just about that time, really quickly, Michael, you touched on it before, you know, starting R.E.M. when you were a teenager and you read the University of Georgia, and you met Peter Buck and Mike Mills and Bill Berry there in Athens.
没错。而且你，我们懂的。但是，是的，抱歉，迈克尔，能简单谈谈那个时候吗，你之前提到过，你在十几岁时组建了R.E.M.，你在佐治亚大学读书，你在雅典遇到了彼得·巴克、迈克·米尔斯和比尔·贝里。
And you guys created REM and your first single, I think, was Radio Free Europe that came out a couple years before your first actual record. Right. You know, it's funny, I listen to, and it's not hard to find just that original recording of Radio Free Europe. And what really astounds me, what I love about it is,
你们创建了R.E.M.，我想你们的第一首单曲是《Radio Free Europe》，它在你们的第一张真正的唱片发行前几年就问世了。对。你知道，很有趣，我听，而且找到《Radio Free Europe》的最初录音并不难。真正让我震惊的是，我喜欢它的地方在于，
from the moment you guys start, it immediately, Mike Mills bass, Bill Berry's drums, Peter Buck's guitar, and your vocals feel like you guys are shot out of a cannon. This is your introduction to the world. And there's something really fantastic and youthful and exuberant about that sound that I really, the more I read about you guys and where you came
从你们开始的那一刻起，迈克·米尔斯的贝斯、比尔·贝里的鼓、彼得·巴克的吉他，以及你的歌声，立刻就让你感觉你们像是从大炮里发射出来的一样。这是你们向世界的自我介绍。那种声音里有一些非常美妙、青春洋溢和充满活力、充满朝气的东西，我真的，我读到越多关于你们和你们的出身
and how you formed the band. And then you re-listen to that song. You guys were, there was so much in those first 30 seconds of that song, man. Thank you. Before the singer starts that song, man. Thank you. Before the singer starts. No, no.
以及你们是如何组建乐队的故事。然后你重新听那首歌。在那个前30秒里有太多东西了，伙计。谢谢你。在歌手开口唱那首歌之前，伙计。谢谢你。在歌手开口唱之前。不，不。
It was a combination of like, you know, like, it was really just abject fear. And then, and then again, like this have absurd, like this is what we're doing. Let's do it. But it's the confidence of youth, too, right? I mean, it's exactly. Exactly.
那是多种因素的结合，你知道的，就像，这真的只是纯粹的恐惧。然后，然后又是那种荒谬的感觉，这就是我们要做的。让我们做吧。这也是青春的自信，对吧？我的意思是，正是如此。完全正确。
I mean, there aren't words to that song. I was just making sounds that felt emotional and that carries over to the whole first album. You know, I really was just singing, feeling. I wasn't singing words or narratives until really the second or third record. Yeah, they talk about them. And was that life's rich pageant that you first felt that turning point or trying to think which record it was? That was the fourth album. That was in 1986, I think.
我的意思是，那首歌没有歌词。我当时只是发出我觉得很有情感的声音，这延续到了整张第一张专辑中。你知道，我真的只是在歌唱感觉。直到第二张或第三张唱片，我才开始唱出文字或叙事。是的，他们谈论过那些。那是《Life's Rich Pageant》吗，你第一次感受到那个转折点，或者我在想那是哪张唱片？那是第四张专辑。我想那是1986年。
And then the one before that is Fables of the Reconstruction or Reconstruction of the Fables. And that's where I was writing. I started fictionalizing the lives of people around me to try to pull myself out of. You know, I realized that my voice was quite powerful and meant a lot to people, but I also, I wasn't really singing about anything,
然后在那之前的一张是《Fables of the Reconstruction》或者说《Reconstruction of the Fables》。正是在那里我开始写作。我开始虚构我身边人的生活，试图把自己从……中拉出来。你知道，我意识到我的声音相当有力量，对人们意义重大，但我也意识到，我其实并没有在唱任何具体的东西，
so I figured I needed this thing about something. So I did the most obvious thing, which is look around and like, oh, that guy's interesting. How can I tell his story? And then I would exaggerate everything to create some moment of epiphany for the chorus or to make, in the words of Peter Buck,
所以我认为我需要唱点什么。于是我做了最显而易见的事情，那就是环顾四周，然后想，哦，那家伙真有趣。我怎么能讲述他的故事呢？然后我会夸张一切，为副歌创造某种顿悟的时刻，或者用彼得·巴克的话来说，
never let the truth get in the way of a good story. So as Alero says, I was able to do that. As a storyteller, he's much better than I am. But you wrote one of the great lyrics, I think, in Fall on Me, which is a feather hits the ground before the weight can leave the air. And I told that to my son, my almost 15 year old today, and he literally went, wow.
永远不要让事实妨碍一个精彩的故事。所以作为一个叙事者，我能够做到这一点。作为一个讲故事的人，他比我强得多。但你写过一首伟大的歌词，我认为是在《Fall on Me》里，“一根羽毛在重力离开空气之前落地”。我今天把这句话告诉我儿子，他快15岁了，他 literalmente 说了声，哇。
It really hit him. It's one of the great lyrics stuff that I've always just adored. I don't know, there's something about, there's something so magical about that idea to me. Can I pop your bubble, Will? Oh, fuck. No, it's, it's, it was, it had to do with gravity and,
这真的触动了他。这是我一直非常崇拜的伟大歌词之一。我不知道，对于这个想法，我总觉得有一种非常神奇的东西。我能打破你的幻想吗，威尔？哦，操。不，这，这，这与重力有关，
and mass, and it was, it was an actual experiment. I think they dropped a pound of feathers and a pound of, what was it, iron, or what is it in the lyric, I don't remember, but something heavy and then something not heavy. But they dropped an equal amount off of the Tower of Pisa, I believe, and to see if they would land at the same time. Oh, shit.
还有质量，这是一个真实的实验。我想他们扔了一磅羽毛和一磅，那是什么来着，铁，或者歌词里到底是什么，我不记得了，但总之是一个重的和一个不重的。但我相信他们从比萨斜塔上扔下了等量的物品，看看它们是否会同时落地。哦，该死。
Well, that's where that lyric comes from. I don't think that actually blows your mind. It did blow my mind. There's something about, I don't know, but even just as an idea, like of using it in a song for me, I find it very poetic and very kind of, I don't know, romantic or something. There's something... He's a very easy label.
好吧，那句歌词就是这么来的。我不认为这真的震撼了你。确实震撼到我了。这其中有些东西，我不知道，但仅仅作为一个想法，比如把它用在一首歌里，我发现它非常具有诗意，也非常，我不知道，浪漫什么的。这里面有一种……他很容易被贴上标签。
He's a label, Michael. That's a... I'm a manchite date. Yeah, if you want romance, you're barking up the right tree. Well, I'm a little bit sentimental and I'm a little bit... Yeah. We'll be right back.
他就是个标签，迈克尔。那是一个……我是个浪漫主义者。是的，如果你想要浪漫，那你可找对人了。好吧，我有点多愁善感，我也有一点……是的。我们马上回来。
Thanks to Vury Clothing for supporting the show. Bury makes premium performance, apparel guys, inspired by the active coastal California lifestyle, an integration of fitness, surf, sport, and art. Everything is designed to work out in, but doesn't look or feel like it. We've been fans of Bury for a long time, so we're excited to tell you about one
感谢Viori Clothing对本节节目的大力支持。Viori生产高端运动休闲服饰，其灵感源自积极的加州海岸生活方式，融合了健身、冲浪、运动和艺术。所有服装的设计都适合运动穿着，但看起来和穿起来却一点也不像运动服。我们一直是Viori的粉丝，所以我们很高兴向大家介绍他们的一款
of their newest products, the Men's Core Jogger. It's everything you love about the Core Short, the same moisture-wicking stretch woven fabric and interior box of brief liner for the ultimate and go anywhere comfort now in a jogger. Right now, I'm wearing the new Ponto Short. I love the Ponto Short. You know what you can do in Ponto shorts? Podcast. You can talk in a podcast while wearing Ponto shorts. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartlets.
最新产品——男士核心慢跑裤。它具备你所钟爱的一切核心短裤的优点：同样具备吸湿排汗弹力梭织面料和内置平角短裤内衬，带来无与伦比的“走到哪舒服到哪”的穿着体验，现在这些优点都被融入到了慢跑裤中。此刻，我正穿着新款Ponto短裤。我太喜欢Ponto短裤了。你知道穿着Ponto短裤能做什么吗？做播客。你可以在穿着Ponto短裤的同时录制播客。Viori是对你幸福感的一笔投资。为我们的听众提供首次购买8折优惠。前往Viori.com/smartlets，为自己挑选地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装。
That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartlets. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over 75 bucks and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash SmartLess and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. I'm really wearing Ponto. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪
网址是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 斜杠 smartlets。你不仅能享受首次购买8折优惠，还能享受美国境内满75美元订单免运费以及免费退货服务。快去 Viori.com/smartlets 探索 Viori 服饰的多功能性吧。我真的穿着Ponto短裤呢。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪
[♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ SmartLess gets support from State Farm. Insurance can be confusing sometimes, right? At least for me. That's why State farm is there for your what ifs because they know the rest of your life is already full of thinking about other things like what if your life was a playlist. Imagine a crazy it would be. Your first song might be a noisy track called I don't know, Kids. The second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership. Then like a hundred more songs called Work, Health, Pets, Cars, Yardwork,
[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ SmartLess 获得 State Farm 的支持。保险有时可能会让人感到困惑，对吧？至少对我是这样。这就是为什么 State Farm 会为你的“万一”保驾护航，因为他们知道你生活的其余部分已经排满了对其他事情的思考，比如，如果你的生活是一份播放列表。想象一下那会有多疯狂。你的第一首歌曲可能是一个喧闹的曲目，叫做，我不知道，名字叫“孩子们”。第二首，是一个诡异的曲目，叫做“拥有房产”。然后还有大约一百首叫做“工作”、“健康”、“宠物”、“汽车”、“庭院杂务”的歌曲，
the playlist goes on, and once you put it on repeat and add shuffle mode, things might not sound all that jazzy. That's why the last track you'd want to add to your life's playlist is called Insurance Uncertainties with lyrics like, what if I'd like to add coverage to my policy, what if I have questions, what if I'm using a metaphor that doesn't really work,
播放列表还在继续，一旦你把它设为单曲循环并开启随机播放模式，事情听起来可能就不会那么美妙了。这就是为什么你最不想加入你生活播放列表的最后一首歌叫做“保险不确定性”，里面包含这样的歌词：“如果我想在我的保单中添加保障怎么办？”“如果我有疑问怎么办？”“如果我使用了一个并不真的管用，但对于广告来说挺好的隐喻怎么办？”
but it's good for an ad. Well, there are some positive notes that can help keep your life in harmony. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, about insurance coverage and policy questions, because that's just what they do. So no matter how noisy your life may get, insurance can still be music to your ears. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Zip Recruiter. Did you know that around 46 million turkeys are eaten on Thanksgiving each year in the US? Think about all of the people
好吧，有一些积极的音符可以帮助你的生活保持和谐。你可以在 State Farm 移动应用程序上提交理赔申请，与真人（包括你的专属保险代理人）交流保险保障和保单问题，因为这就是他们的工作。因此，无论你的生活变得多么喧闹，保险依然可以成为你耳中的美妙音乐。像好邻居一样，State Farm 一直在你身边。本期 SmartLess 节目部分内容由 ZipRecruiter 赞助播出。你知道美国每年感恩节要吃掉大约 4600 万只火鸡吗？想想看，有多少人
involved in getting that turkey from the farm to your table, the turkey farm laborers, food safety inspectors, food production workers, and more. It's not easy to find people with the specific skills required for these jobs, but if you need to hire for these jobs or any other job, there's only one place to go, zip recruiter. And right now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. How does zip recruiter help you find top talent for hard-to-fill roles? Zyprecutor sends your job to 100 plus job sites, so you reach more of the right people.
参与了将火鸡从农场送到你餐桌的过程：火鸡养殖场工人、食品安全检查员、食品生产工人等等。要找到具备这些工作所需特定技能的人并不容易，但如果你需要招聘这些岗位或任何其他岗位，只有一个地方可去，那就是 ZipRecruiter。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartless免费试用它。ZipRecruiter 如何帮你为难以填补的职位找到最顶尖的人才？ZipRecruiter 会将你的职位发布到 100 多个招聘网站上，让你触达更多合适的人选。
Zyprecutor's powerful technology does the work for you. It scans thousands of resumes to find great matches for your job. Zyprecutor lets you invite the most qualified people to apply to your job, to help you stand out amongst the competition. So, if you're hiring, discover what Zippercruder brings to the table. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder get a quality candidate within the first
ZipRecruiter 强大的技术会为你完成这些工作。它会扫描数千份简历，为你的职位寻找绝佳匹配。ZipRecruiter 允许你邀请最具资格的人员来申请你的职位，帮助你在竞争中脱颖而出。因此，如果你正在招聘，快来体验 ZipRecruiter 能带来什么。五分之四在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。
day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try Zippercruder 4 free. Zippercruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com slash SMA RT LES S Zippercruder, the smartest way to hire. and now back to the show. Michael, is there any draw for you to continue communicating and being creative in the musical space? Any more? Or are you finding all of the sort of the itches
现在就访问这个专属网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次强调，网址是 zippercruder.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在让我们回到节目中。迈克尔，你是否还有任何动力去继续在音乐领域进行交流和创作？或者你发现所有的
being scratched in other places? No, I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. creative in the musical space anymore? Or are you finding all of the sort of the itches being scratched in other places?
挠痒痒的需求已经在其他地方得到了满足？不，我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。在音乐领域进行创作？或者你发现所有的需求都在其他地方得到了满足？
I can't believe I'm talking to three of you guys. I'm just gonna start there because I'm such a big fan of each of you. This is really such an honor to be on the show, but I have 75 things I wanna tell you as a fan as soon as you answer this question. Okay, all right. Actually, thank you for asking.
我简直不敢相信我在和你们三个人说话。我就从这里开始，因为我是你们每个人的超级粉丝。能上这个节目真的是我的荣幸，但作为一个粉丝，只要你回答完这个问题，我有75件事想告诉你。好的，好的。其实，谢谢你问起。
I started with the show and Milan. That's happening. Yeah. That opens in December itself for three months. I'm really excited about it. And I'm absolutely fucking terrified. And so I know that I'm doing something right. I'm gonna do a big Google search as soon as we're done
我从米兰的展览开始。那就要发生了。对。它将在12月开幕，展期三个月。我对此真的超级兴奋。而且我他妈的绝对吓坏了。所以，我知道我正在做正确的事情。等我们做完这个，我打算立刻进行一次大范围的谷歌搜索，
with this and take a look at all this stuff. I can't. You're not gonna find much, but I can now. I can, it'll, I think I know when you guys are broadcasting this, so I can tell you the name of it. The title is, wait for it, I have lost, and I have been lost, but for now I'm flying high. That's the title of the show.
看看所有这些东西。我不能。你找不到太多东西，但我现在可以了。我可以，它会，我想我知道你们什么时候播出这个，所以我可以告诉你它的名字。它的名字是，等等，我迷失过，我也曾迷失，但现在我正在高飞。这就是展览的名字。
That's great. That's great. I love it. I'm also working on a solo album, and it's a bit embarrassing because I started this when I was 19, and I'm now, you know, Methuselah. I've become father time as time marched on. But I'm doing my first solo record,
太棒了。太棒了。我喜欢。我还在制作一张个人专辑，这有点尴尬，因为我19岁时就开始做这个了，而我现在，你知道的，老态龙钟。随着时间流逝，我已经成了时间老人。但我正在制作我的第一张个人唱片，
and it's about half done. Can I ask you what sort of world that is in as far as instrumentation goes and band size and all that? Not what you might expect. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I love electronic music and ambient music. Opened with a sitar. It does not.
而且大约完成了一半。我能问一下，就配乐和乐队规模而言，它属于什么样的世界吗？不是你可能预期的那样。对。对。我的意思是，我喜欢电子音乐和环境音乐。以西塔琴开场。并不是。
That would be great, though. God, that's a good idea. I knew you'reed with a sitar. It does not. That would be great though. God, that's a good idea. I knew you're going to say more electronic. I knew it. Sorry, keep going. Really? Yeah.
不过那倒挺棒的。天哪，这是个好主意。我知道你会以西塔琴开场。并没有。不过那倒挺棒的。天哪，这是个好主意。我知道你会说更偏电子。我就知道。抱歉，继续。真的吗？对。
I mean, I really, you know, some of the stuff that we do. These are the shades. These are actual glasses that I need. I guess. We all do. Thank you. I should be wearing it. So more electronic, huh?
我的意思是，我真的，你知道，我们做的一些事情。这些是眼镜。这些是我实际需要的眼镜。我想。我们都这样。谢谢。我应该戴着它的。所以更偏电子，是吗？
Because you, I mean, REM I mean, REM was so instrumental. Yeah, I'm right. I realized really, when I started writing on my own and composing, because I never wrote music, I always responded to what those guys gave me. And I'm speaking to Peter Buck, Mike Mills, and Bill Berry, when he was a part of the band. And so I always just responded to their music. And as a, you know, I hear harmony everywhere. It's actually a little bit of a problem.
因为你，我的意思是，R.I.M. —— 我的意思是，R.I.M. 太具有器乐色彩了。是的，没错。我真的意识到，当我开始独自创作和谱曲时——因为我从来不写音乐，我总是对那些家伙给我的东西做出回应。我在说彼得·巴克、迈克·米尔斯和比尔·贝里，当他还在这支乐队里的时候。所以我总是只对他们的音乐做出回应。而且作为一个，你知道，我到处都能听到和声。这其实有点小问题。
And then I would hear harmony and melody, and then I would compose the words to that. But I'd never composed music myself. So I started that only to find out that it's really a lot fucking harder than you think it is. But I'm doing okay. But I knew right away that I couldn't do some airsats version of R&M.
然后我会听到和声与旋律，然后我根据那些来创作歌词。但我自己从来没有谱写过音乐。所以我开始这样做，结果却发现这他妈的比你想象的要难得多。但我做得还不错。不过我立刻就知道我不能做任何山寨版的R&M。
I don't need electric guitar and bass and drums because it's just going to be a pathetic comparison to being a part of, in my opinion, and I'm gonna tune my own horn here. But I was a part of one of the greatest bands and I'm gonna to my own horn here, but I was a part of, you know, one of the greatest bands of all time. And those guys, I know. So I'm looking for a different arena
我不需要电吉他和贝斯还有鼓，因为那只会与成为其中一部分形成悲惨的对比，依我之见——我要在这里自吹自擂一下。但我曾是一支最伟大的乐队的一部分，我要在这里自吹自擂一下，但我曾是，你知道的，史上最伟大的乐队之一的一部分。而那些家伙，我知道。所以我正在寻找一个不同的竞技场
to place my voice in. Are you gonna do all of it yourself? Like are you doing playing all the keyboard, like all the electronic stuff yourself or you? No, I can't play a single thing. I'm okay on the cube. I start, everything starts with synthesizer, and then
来安放我的声音。你会全部自己来吗？比如你会自己演奏所有的键盘、所有的电子部分，还是你？不，我什么都不会弹。我在键盘上还行。我开始，一切都从合成器开始，然后
and drums. So it's it's it's pretty beat heavy. I mean about half of the work is is you know basically disco. I can't wait to hear it. Yeah no kidding. It's just I'm super excited about it. Yeah there's some really unexpected things are coming uh lyrically. I'm going into some territory that is actually deeply frightening. But but again if if I'm terrified then I know that I'm going into some territory that is actually deeply frightening. But again, if I'm terrified, then I know that I'm doing something right. And I'm absolutely terrified, so that's good. I think that that's the greatest place to be. I don't know how you guys feel about it. Those moments, you know, you've had those moments where you're doing something
还有鼓。所以它，它，它节奏感很强。我的意思是，大约一半的作品都是，你知道的，基本上是迪斯科。我等不及要听了。对，真的吗。我真的超级兴奋。是的，在歌词上会有一些非常意想不到的事情。我正在涉足一个实际上让人深感恐惧的领域。但是，但话说回来，如果我感到害怕，那么我知道我正在涉足一个实际上让人深感恐惧的领域。但是，但话说回来，如果我感到害怕，那么我知道我正在做正确的事情。而且我绝对感到害怕，所以这挺好的。我认为那是最好的状态。我不知道你们对此作何感想。那些时刻，你知道的，你们有过这样的时刻：当你正在做某件事，
or you're taking a risk or you're at an olem and you're like, God, I'm so fucking scared. And yet, I think this know, you're taking a risk or you're at an olem and you're like, God, I'm so fucking scared. And yet, I think this is where I should be. Because if I'm comfortable, then right on the edge of what you think you can handle is a good spot to be. Yeah, yeah. Oh my gosh.
或者你在冒着风险，或者你正处于人生路口，然后你想，天哪，我他妈太害怕了。然而，我觉得这就是我应该在的地方。因为如果你感到舒适，那么在你能承受的极限边缘，就是一个好地方。对，对。哦，天哪。
You mentioned Harmony and one of the things that for me was one of the real hallmarks of REM. And I agree with you, one of the great American bands. And anybody wants to challenge me, I'll meet you online. But one of the real hallmarks of REM was the incredible harmonizing you did, especially you and Mike Mills. I challenge anybody to find something that's more,
你提到了和声，对我来说，R.E.M.的真正标志之一。我同意你的看法，这是伟大的美国乐队之一。如果有人想挑战我，我随时奉陪。但R.E.M.的真正标志之一就是你们所做的令人难以置信的和声，尤其是你和迈克·米尔斯。我向任何人发起挑战，让他们找出比听你和迈克·米尔斯在像《Fall on Me》这样的歌曲中，或者在《Superman》中进行和声更，
I don't know, musically pleasing than listening to you and Mike Mills harmonize with each other on songs like Like Follow Me or on Superman, which I didn't realize was a cover. And I saw the video of you guys with the original writer back in 86 from In Illinois where you brought him on. But also one of the great harmonizing, it's just mind blowing, man. Well, that's Mike. That's really, I mean, Mike has a... Mike and though are incredibly musical and... But encyclopedically knowledgeable about music, I'm not. I'm a complete... Like, I really don't know the first thing about music.
我不知道，更让人在音乐上感到愉悦的东西了。我以前没意识到《Superman》是一首翻唱歌曲。我看到过你们在1986年伊利诺伊州与原作者同台演出的视频，当时你们把他请了上来。而且那也是最伟大的和声之一，简直让人脑洞大开，伙计。哦，那是迈克。真的，我的意思是，迈克拥有一个……迈克和……都极具音乐才华，而且……对音乐有着百科全书般的知识，我没有。我完全是个……就像，我对音乐真的可谓一窍不通。
I hate to break into you. I hate to break into you. Really good. And so, as uncomfortable as that may be, send me some R&M albums, well. I will. But what would you, what would you, what was that first moment like
真不忍心打断你。真不忍心打断你。非常好。所以，尽管这可能会让人感到不舒服，威尔，给我寄几张R&M的专辑吧。我会的。但你会，你会，那第一个瞬间是什么样的？
when you and Mike and Bill potentially did harmonize? Like how did that come up? Do you remember that? I remember the moment when vocal arrangement became a concept that I was like, oh holy shit, that's a thing. Like I knew about musical arrangement, but we were working in Memphis in 1986.
当你在迈克和比尔可能进行和声的时候？那是怎么产生的？你还记得那一刻吗？我记得人声编曲成为一个概念的那一刻，当时我想，哦，天哪，这居然是个东西。就像我知道音乐编曲一样，但我们当时在1986年的孟菲斯工作。
And we were in a studio that was a kind of mostly country music. But in the other studio was Mavis Staples and her producer Reverend Al Green and And then this guy who I saw all the time at the coffee machine. So finally, I was like are you are you a musician? Are you seeing what do you do? And he said oh, I do vocal arrangement and it hit like it's like this Like seismic blast like took my face off and I was like, fuck, you can arrange vocals. You can arrange vocals. Did I say that right?
我们在一个录音室里，那里主要做乡村音乐。但在另一个录音室里有Mavis Staples和她的制作人Al Green牧师，然后还有这个我在咖啡机旁经常看到的家伙。所以我最后忍不住问他，你是音乐人吗？你在做什么？他说，哦，我做声效编排，那种感觉就像是个重击，像是一场地震轰得我面目全非，我当时想，操，你居然能编排人声。你会编美人声。我刚才说得对吗？
Did I mess it up? No, you did. He was the vocal arranger for May the Staples in Reverend Al Green. And I was like, wow. And so then I was like, hey, I have an idea. I have an idea. I have an idea.
我搞砸了吗？不，你没有。他是Mavis Staples和Al Green牧师的人声编曲。当时我就想，哇。然后我就说，嘿，我有个主意。我有个主意。我有个主意。
Mike would sing most of them. But eventually the band were making fun of me because I was doing all these harmonies that were essentially the Beatles. And I famously or kind of infamously didn't grow up with the Beatles. So I love the monkeys and I love the Archies and I love the banana splits. But I was a kid and I didn't have an older brother or sister who really loved music. And I have an older sister who I love immensely and she's got incredible taste. But at the time, you know, we weren't no one listened to the Beatles in my household.
Mike通常会唱大部分。但后来乐队开始取笑我，因为我加入的所有和声基本上都是披头士风格的。众所周知，或者说有点人尽皆知的是，我从小不听披头士。所以我喜欢Monkees，喜欢Archies，还喜欢Banana Splits。但我当时还是个孩子，家里也没有一个真正热爱音乐的哥哥或姐姐。我有一个非常爱我的姐姐，她的品味好得不得了。但在当时，你知道的，我们家里没人听披头士。
So anyway, I wound up kind of recreating something that it was always in the background for me. But Mike's the secret sauce there. Mike is true. But you were doing it before you knew what you were doing. I guess it's my point. Well, they knew, he knew. I didn't know.
所以不管怎样，我最后有点像是在重现某种一直存在于我背景音乐里的东西。但Mike才是其中的秘密武器。Mike确实是。但在你真正懂之前，你就在做了。我想这就是我的重点。好吧，他们懂，他懂。我不懂。
But I also love your candor, because you know that thing where people go, like a reference like a song or like a film or a book or something, and they go, you end up just go, yeah, yeah, yeah, I know. And you're like, no, you don't fucking know. And I love that you're just like, I didn't know the Beatles.
但我同时也很喜欢你的坦率，因为你知道那种情况，当别人提到某个东西，比如一首歌、一部电影或一本书什么的，然后他们说，你最后只会说，对，对，对，我知道。而你会觉得，不，你根本不知道个屁。我特别喜欢你这种直说“我不知道披头士”的态度。
I didn't listen to them in that way. And I think a lot of people have revision as history when they talk about their own story. I don't even know how to spell it or why they were called. I thought it was Sean just found out why the Beatles were called the Beatles. What was that Sean? Spell spelled B-E-A. Yeah.
我没有那样听过他们的歌。而且我觉得很多人在讲自己的故事时，都会带有修正主义的历史观。我甚至不知道该怎么拼写它，也不知道他们为什么叫这个名字。肖恩刚刚才发现披头士为什么叫披头士。那是怎么回事，肖恩？拼写是 B-E-A。对。
I thought it was a shock. I didn't know it's like the beat. They're making a beat. Oh, yeah, I think so. I thought it was. That's a funny thing to not know. That's why it is a funny thing to me. We have a shock in hanging out with this guy, Michael.
我以前以为是个震惊。我不知道那就像是节拍（beat）。他们在打出节拍。哦，对，我想是的。我以前以为是这样。不知道这个还挺搞笑的。对我来说，这就是为什么这事很有趣。我们在和这个叫迈克尔的家伙闲逛时发现的。
It's a really funny thing to not know. Yeah. And he thought Kennedy was assassinated in DC. So it's just, it's a fountain. He did, Michael, we went on this tour and we went and we walked, where were you drove by? Like the Washington money, you mean or something, JB? Yeah.
不知道这个真的挺搞笑的。对。而且他以为肯尼迪是在华盛顿特区被刺杀的。所以简直是个笑话。他确实这么以为，迈克尔，我们有次去巡演，然后我们去散步，你开车路过了哪里？华盛顿纪念碑什么的吗，JB？对。
And he said, huh, isn't this just about where Ken as he's looking over both shoulders, Kennedy was assassinating right around here. Oh, Jason goes, no, that was in Dallas. You fucking idiot. Welcome to America. Um, hey, I'll go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. No, no, you coach. No, Sean, it's your turn. Because I know we're all. Yeah. I can't wait to go ahead. Michael, hi, I'm Sean and I'm a huge fan of yours.
然后他说，哈，肯尼迪不就是在这一带被刺杀的吗？他边说边警惕地看着两边。哦，杰森说，不，那是在达拉斯。你个蠢货。欢迎来到美国。嗯，嘿，你继续。你继续。你继续。不，不，你先请。不，肖恩，轮到你了。因为我知道我们都在。对。我迫不及待想继续。迈克尔，嗨，我是肖恩，我是你的超级粉丝。
You know, when I was in high school, you basically were one of the, you know, we had to Peshmoan on us. Failing out of high school. Just asking. And high school. Yeah, were one of the, you know, we had the Peshmoan on us. Failing out of high school. And high school, yeah, 88 was the first time I heard, oh my God, the album so embarrassed. In 1988. The album that came out in 88. It would be green. Probably.
你知道的，当我还在上高中时，基本上你就是那个，你知道的，我们有Depeche Mode在听。高中差点辍学。随便问问。还有高中。对，88年是我第一次听到，哦天哪，那张专辑太让人惊艳了。在1988年。那张88年发行的专辑。应该是《Green》吧。
Green, right, green. I know, in a song every word. And so, anyway, so you along with the Peshmoan and all these, but like Tori Amos in 10,000 maniacs and all these other groups that I absolutely loved. I was like a, I was a music major. So I try to listen to as much music as possible and you were part of my defining, you know, young childhood, young adulthood.
《Green》，对，《Green》。我知道，每首歌的歌词都倒背如流。所以，不管怎样，你连同Depeche Mode以及所有这些，比如1988年的Tori Amos和10,000 Maniacs，还有我绝对热爱的所有其他乐队。我当时是个音乐专业学生。所以我尽量听尽可能多的音乐，而你们是我定义青少年前期、青年后期的一部分。
You were a major in the music army. It's, yeah, it's a big deal to meet you and you mean a lot to me. So that said, I have just a couple of things I want to say. That said, I have some notes. Yeah. One is, I sat right next to you with our friend Jimmy Burrows and a play that Woody Harrelson was starting and,
你是音乐大军里的专业生。这，是的，能见到你真是件大事，你对我很重要。话虽如此，我只有几件事想说。话虽如此，我有一些笔记。其一，我当时就坐在你旁边，和我们的朋友Jimmy Burrows一起看伍迪·哈里森主演的一部戏剧，
and I sat right next to you. And I don't think you knew who I was or whatever. And you had glitter on your face and I thought these are coolest guys in the world. And I was so nervous, I never said hello. So I'm glad I'm from hello now. And I was so nervous. I never said hello. So I'm glad I'm from the low now. And I was like, Jimmy, I said to Jimmy, I was like, that's fucking Michael's type sitting right next to me.
我当时就坐在你旁边。而且我觉得你根本不知道我是谁或者别的什么。你脸上还画着亮片，我觉得你们是世界上最酷的人。我当时太紧张了，甚至没跟打招呼。所以我很高兴现在能跟你打招呼。我当时太紧张了。我从来没打过招呼。所以我很高兴现在能打招呼。我当时想，吉米，我对吉米说，那特么不是迈克尔·斯泰普就坐在我旁边吗。
I was freaking out. But anyway, and then talking about her. Tell me, I always need to know place first. What city was that in New York City on Broadway? New York, what do you hear, Olsen was starring. What was it? I don't remember the name. It was really about years and years ago.
我当时快吓疯了。但无论如何，然后说到她。告诉我，我总是得先弄清楚地点。那是哪个城市？纽约市的百老汇吗？纽约，伍迪·哈里森主演的。那是哪部？我不记得名字了。那是好多好多年以前的事了。
I go into blackout with like weddings, funerals and plays. I have to work on it? I don't remember the name. I was really bad with years and years ago. I go into blackout with like, Wedding's, Finals and play as I have to work on the title. I don't know. I think I was the real. Jason wakes up in a blackout. Yeah. Jason can't remember anything. You can talk about something we did last year and Jason go, I was there. Yeah, I can really.
我对婚礼、葬礼和戏剧这种事都会直接断片。我得好好想想？我不记得名字了。我对好多好多年以前的事真的很不在行。我对婚礼、葬礼和戏剧这种事都会直接断片，我得想想剧名。我不知道。我觉得我是真的。杰森醒来时处于断片状态。Yeah。杰森什么也记不住。你可以聊聊我们去年做过的事，然后杰森会说，我当时也在。是的，我真的会这样。
Yeah. But anyway, so the other thing was harmonies. What Will was saying, you know, I'm something is out of reach that 10,000 maniacs on that you saying backup on That's when I was they came I was on the entertainment committee in college We'd get all the bands. I would try so hard to get REM to come But we got 10,000 maniacs to come and I was practicing piano in the rehearsal room where there's like 10 pianos because that was a piano major Right and Natalie merchant is right across me playing at college. I'm like, oh my god because she was performing that
是啊。但无论如何，另一件事是和声。正如Will所说，你知道的，有些东西是够不着的，10000 Maniacs的那些，你在里面唱和声。那是当我在上大学的娱乐委员会时，我们总能请到各种乐队。我曾极力想让REM来，但我们请来了10000 Maniacs，我当时在排练室里练钢琴，那里大概有10台钢琴，因为我是钢琴专业嘛，对吧，而Natalie Merchant当时就在我旁边弹奏。我当时想，我的天哪，因为她当时正在演出。
I actually need a break and I thought I dreamed that Michael's type was gonna come on stage and seeing Harmony to that thing. But my last thing I wanted to say, but you didn't show up. But the last thing I wanted to say was I was dating this guy and losing my religion, you know the chorus, oh god, how does it go? I'm soon nervous now. I think I thought it, yeah. I think it's not a chorus, not a chorus. I think it's not a chorus. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
我其实需要休息一下，我想象着迈克尔·斯泰普能上台为那首歌唱和声。但我最后想说的是，你当时没出现。不过我最后想说的是，我当时在和一个男生约会，还有《Losing My Religion》，你知道那个副歌，哦天哪，它是怎么唱的？我现在太紧张了。我想我是想到了，对。我觉得那不是副歌，不是副歌。我觉得那不是副歌。对，对，对，对，对，对，对。
I thought you tried it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think, so I was dating this guy, and we were trying to send your harmonies, right? And I think I started trying to try whatever, and he couldn't do it, I stopped dating him. That a little good, yeah. Good move, good move.
我以为你试过了。对，对，对，对，对，对，对。我想，所以我当时在跟这个男的约会，我们在试着唱你的和声，对吧？然后我想我开始试着唱什么来着，但他唱不出来，我就和他分手了。这操作挺好，对。好招，好招。
Way to go. I was like, what are you talking about? How could you not? It's just a third. It's just third. and he couldn't do it, I stopped dating him. That'll do. Good move. Good move. Way to go. I was like, what are you talking about? How could you not? It's just a third. It's just third. You sound like you had a pretty wired though. Oh, yeah.
干得漂亮。我当时想，你在说什么？你怎么可能不会？这只是个三度。这只是三度而已。但他唱不出来，我就和他分手了。这就够了。好招。好招。干得漂亮。我当时想，你在说什么？你怎么可能不会？这只是个三度。这只是三度而已。听起来你当时还挺有情调的。哦，是的。
I was just having a good time. I thought I had a bad time. Not a shred of bloody shit. Michael, am I right in remembering that you dipped your toe in film producing for a period there in the 90s or early 2000s. 25 years. Yeah, I was a film producer for 25 years. Really? Yeah, I kind of stopped. What did you did you love it and then didn't love it or always hated it or miss it and loved it the whole time? I loved working with I loved working with people in the film industry, with all the creative people, but all the money people drove me up the fucking wall.
我当时只是玩得很开心。我还以为我过得很惨呢。一点狗屁都没有。迈克尔，我没记错的话，你在90年代或2000年代初的时候，曾在电影制片领域涉足过一段时间吧。25年。是的，我当了25年的电影制片人。真的吗？是的，我算是停下来了。那你以前是热爱它后来不爱了，还是自始至终都很讨厌，或者一直很怀念并热爱着？我喜欢和电影行业的人一起工作，和所有有创意的人一起合作，但所有的金主钱串子把我气得要死。
And it's just so fraught with compromise, you know, with music and with art and with photography and with all the things that I really kind of express for myself, I'm able to really be as wrong as I want to be and completely uncompromise with film and TV. It's always a compromise. You guys know that much more than I do. And but that said, you know, I worked with some incredible people. I made some incredible lifelong friendships and along with what he, Harold Sin, being one of them,
而且这其中充满了妥协，你知道的，与音乐、艺术、摄影以及所有我真正用来表达自我的方式相比，我在做电影和电视时，能够随心所欲地犯错，完全不用妥协。但电影和电视总是伴随着妥协。你们比我更清楚这一点。话虽如此，你知道的，我合作过一些不可思议的人。我结下了几段不可思议的终生友谊，伍迪·哈里森就是其中之一，
we're very, very close. He and Laura are like the dearest people to me. And Natalie actually speaking to Natalie. I saw her perform recently in Chateau, New York with a symphony of the place. I'm a play star. She's incredible. But yeah, I did, I produced Beane John Malkovich. Yeah. I'm really proud of that.
我们非常非常亲密。他和劳拉就像是我最亲爱的人。说到娜塔莉，实际上。我最近在纽约查托看过她的演出，那是和当地的交响乐团合作的。我是个戏迷。她太不可思议了。不过是的，我确实制作过《傀儡人生》（Being John Malkovich）。是的。我对此感到非常骄傲。
That's incredible. I executive produced Velvet Gold Mine with Todd Haynes. And you talked to Todd or to Spike at all in your? I talked to Spike all the time. We used to live across the street from each other. Oh yeah. I love Spike. He's one of the funniest dudes.
这太不可思议了。我担任了托德·海因斯执导的《天鹅绒金矿》的执行制片人。你跟托德或斯派克聊过吗？我经常和斯派克聊天。我们以前住在马路对面。哦，是吗？我太喜欢斯派克了。他是个极其搞笑的家伙。
Yeah. I met him when he was a teenager with through Jane Pratt. Actually, she was doing a magazine called Sassy. And they had a skateboard, like boy version of Sassy. And Spike was one of the two guys that were a part of that. So he was a kid when I met him. I was also a kid, but anyway. It's such a filmmaker.
是的。我是在他十几岁的时候通过简·普拉特认识他的。其实，她当时正在办一本叫《Sassy》的杂志。他们当时有一个类似男生版的《Sassy》滑板杂志。斯派克就是参与其中的两个家伙之一。所以我认识他时他还是个孩子。我当时也是个孩子，不过不管怎样。他真是一个天生的电影人。
Yeah, we kind of grew up together, and he's amazing. And then my best friend, Jim McKay, that's kind of more, the Hollywood at part of my film production was much more truncated than the work that I did out of New York, was much more truncated than the work that I did out of New York, which was more independent film. Did you ever think about maybe scoring a film?
对，我们算是共同成长起来的，他太棒了。然后是我最好的朋友吉姆·麦凯，相比于我在纽约之外做的工作，我在好莱坞的电影制作生涯要短得多，我在纽约之外做的工作要多得多，那些更多是独立电影。你有没有想过为电影配乐？
Yeah, actually the band scored a film called Man on the Moon with Milo Shoforman. Oh, right. Oh, yeah. Based on a song that we wrote called Man on the Moon, which was about Andy Kaufman. Yeah. And the comedian, and it kind of brought Andy back into as he had died and had kind of been
对，其实乐队曾为米洛什·福尔曼导演的电影《月亮上的男人》做过配乐。哦，对。哦，是的。基于我们写的一首名为《月亮上的男人》的歌，那是关于安迪·考夫曼的。对。那个喜剧演员，这首歌某种程度上让安迪在去世且快被人们遗忘后，
forgotten. And this friend of ours brought some VHS tapes to Studio and Seattle and we were there working and I watched the tapes and then there was this piece of music that the band loved but I couldn't I couldn't find it couldn't find it couldn't it. And I went on a long walk the last day that we were in the studio, and I wrote Man on the Moon walking around the blocks of downtown Seattle. And I recorded it that night, and we gave it to the record company the next day, and that was that.
重新回到了大众视野。我们的一个朋友带了一些VHS录像带到西雅图的录音室，当时我们正在那里工作，我看了这些录像带，然后里面有一段乐队非常喜欢的音乐，但我找不到了，怎么也找不到。在我们离开录音室的最后一天，我散了很久的步，在西雅图市中心的街区里转悠时写下了《月亮上的男人》。那天晚上我把它录了下来，第二天就交给了唱片公司，事情就是这样。
No, no, no. It's crazy, it's crazy. I mean, that really happened. That's super nuts. That's magic. That is crazy. I love hearing those stories when bands, I remember the story of reading
不，不，不。这太疯狂了，太疯狂了。我是说，这真的发生了。这简直太扯了。这就是魔法。这太疯狂了。我喜欢听这种故事，当乐队，我记得我曾在哪里读过
somewhere that Paul Weller talks about writing that entertainment in 10 minutes coming home from the pub and I'm like, you know, one of the jam's great songs and being like, wow, that's amazing. Or like you writing Man on the Moon a song that everybody knows it massive hit that was so like, and that you wrote it walking around and gave it to the record company the next day. and that you wrote it walking around and gave it to the record company the next day. But then someone heard the song, fell in love with Andy Kaufman all over again, wrote a script and it got into Milocious Hands and he's one of my heroes. Yeah, but I felt like he was. And he put together a great cast and did a great, made a great film, I think.
保罗·韦勒谈到从酒吧回家时花10分钟写下《A Town Called Malice》，我想，你知道的，那是The Jam乐队伟大的歌曲之一，然后觉得，哇，这太惊人了。或者像你写了《月亮上的男人》这样一首人尽皆知、大获成功的巨作，而且是在散步时写出来的，第二天就交给了唱片公司。而且竟然有人听了这首歌，重新爱上了安迪·考夫曼，然后写了剧本并交到了米洛什手里，他可是我的偶像之一。对，但我觉得他确实是。而且他组建了一支出色的演员阵容，拍出了一部非常棒的电影，我是这么觉得的。
But the band wound up scoring that. Yeah. I want to ask you about Thomas, if you don't mind, and we don't have to, if you don't. But just being in a relationship, I'd say. Oh, yeah. My boyfriend. Yeah, I just, just being in a relationship
但乐队最终还是为那部电影做了配乐。是的。如果你不介意的话，我想问问关于托马斯的事，如果我们不想聊也可以。但就是关于处于一段恋系，我想说。哦，对。我的男友。对，我只是，只是处于一段关系中
with another artist. We'll thought I was going to say with another man. But with another artist. A different. A different. A different man. What does that like? Because you're both photographers.
跟另一个艺术家。Wills以为我要说跟另一个男人。但其实是跟另一个艺术家。不同的。不同的。不同的男人。那是什么感觉？因为你们俩都是摄影师。
Obviously, he's very well respected. He's much better than I am. Tell Tracy and me who Thomas is. Thomas is Toma, his, his, his, his French Thomas Dozle. And he's an artist who works mostly in photography. And he's, he's a master portraitist. So he puts me to shame.
显然，他备受尊敬。他比我优秀得多。告诉翠西和我，托马斯是谁。托马斯是托马（Toma），他，他，他，他是法国人，托马斯·多兹（Thomas Dozle）。他是一位主要从事摄影创作的艺术家。而且他是一位肖像摄影大师。所以跟他比起来我简直自愧不如。
And so do you guys, what, what are the, the heated discussions like? Like do you guys get injured about? He'll do it. Yeah. Voices. Voices. There's a story here. Well, I mean, it's an ongoing saga, but both of us love art.
那么你们俩，你们会有什么激烈的讨论吗？比如你们会争论吗？他会。对。声音。声音。这里面有个故事。好吧，我的意思是，这是一部正在进行中的传奇，但我们俩都热爱艺术。
And as I said, he's French. And so he has such a different perspective on art. And everything growing up in France and growing up the way that he did. And so yeah, we really get into it, but it's absolutely supportive, you know. But he has opinions, that's for sure. As do I. I mean, we have the type of relationship where we're able to say really difficult things about everything,
正如我所说，他是法国人。所以他对艺术有着如此不同的视角。在法国长大以及以他的方式长大所带来的一切。所以，是的，我们确实会深入探讨，但这绝对是相互支持的，你知道的。不过他确实有自己的观点，那是肯定的。我也有。我的意思是，我们的关系模式是，我们可以对任何事情说出非常严厉的真话，
but we're speaking here about work. We're able to say, you know what, that's not, you know, you could do better or try again, try again, or... Do both of you work with film or with digital photography? He works with mostly film for the serious work that he's doing. We're in our first show together, actually not our first show together, but we're in a show together that's opening in Cincinnati
但我们在这里讨论的是工作。我们能够说，你知道的，那不行，你知道的，你可以做得更好，或者再试一次，再试一次，或者……你们两个是用胶片还是数码摄影创作？对于他正在进行的严肃创作，他主要使用胶片。事实上，我们即将迎来我们的第一个联合展，其实不是第一个联合展，但我们有一个联展将于十月份在辛辛那提开幕
in October. It's a group show about collage. And just this morning before we got on the phone, he sent me the two images that he's putting up there. It's two noods. It's a woman named Rihanna Kubik and a guy named Jesper Jost, both very, very different, both working in art, but they're this incredible. I wish you could see them, but they're these
那是一个关于拼贴艺术的群展。就在今天早上我们打电话之前，他把准备在那儿展出的两张照片发给了我。那是两个裸体。一个叫蕾娜·库比克（Rihanna Kubik）的女人和一个叫杰斯帕·约斯特（Jesper Jost）的男人，两人截然不同，都从事艺术工作，但他们真的是太不可思议了。我真希望你们能看到它们，但它们真的是
really, really stunning portraits. So he's a great portraitist along the lines of Peter Huzhar, or Gasha, I can't even think of who else, maybe Richard Abadon. And I, as a, I'm more of, I'm more of like a snapshot guy. Like, I snap pictures as a diary, and sometimes I'll see something that catches my eye. I see things differently than regular people, and so I'm able to kind of present a different perspective. But, but what he does is profoundly really thoughtful. We'll be right back.
非常非常惊艳的肖像作品。所以他是一位杰出的肖像摄影师，风格类似于彼得·胡扎尔（Peter Hujar）、加沙（Gasha），我甚至想不起还有谁，也许还有理查德·阿维顿（Richard Avedon）。而我，作为一个，我更像是一个，我更像是一个随手拍的人。比如，我把拍照当作写日记，有时我会看到吸引我眼球的东西。我跟常人看待事物的方式不同，所以我能够呈现出不同的视角。但是，他所做的事情是深邃且真正深思熟虑的。我们马上回来。
profoundly really thoughtful. We'll be right back. Smarlers is sponsored by BetterHelp. It's the end of the year. It's all the seasons are happening. And guess what else is happening? Weather changes. And it gets a little gloomy outside. It gets overcast.
深邃且真正深思熟虑的。我们马上回来。SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助播出。一年快过完了。各种季节都在更迭。你们猜还发生了什么？天气变了。外面开始变得有点阴沉。天空多云。
The sun kind of goes away for a few months. A lot of people get the seasonal blues, as they say. And I get it sometimes a little bit. When the sun's away for so long, it's, I don't know, I don't know if it's getting older or what it is, but it's real and it's there, and it's true for a lot of people. So this time of year can be a lot,
太阳好像消失了好几个月。正如人们所说，很多人会患上季节性情绪失调。我有时也会有一点这种感觉。当太阳消失这么久的时候，我不知道，我不知道是因为变老了还是怎么回事，但这是真实存在的，就在那里，对很多人来说都是如此。所以每到这个时候可能会让人压力很大，
and it's natural to feel some sadness or anxiety about it. But adding something new and positive to your life can counteract some of those feelings. Therapy can be a bright spot, amid all the stress and change, something that look forward to to to to make you feel grounded, and to give you the tools to manage everything going on. I know therapy for me does give me the tools,
对这种状况感到悲伤或焦虑是很自然的。但给生活增添一些积极的新事物可以抵消部分这种情绪。在压力和变故中，心理咨询可以成为一个亮点，成为你所期待的事物，让你感到踏实，并为你提供应对一切状况的工具。我知道心理咨询确实给了我应对的工具，
and if I am feeling gloomy or down or have seasonal blues, or whatever creeps into my mind, I always talk to a therapist, and it always helps. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help, a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just spill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch
如果我感到情绪低落、沮丧、有季节性抑郁，或者任何潜入我脑海的负面情绪，我总是会跟心理咨询师聊聊，这总是很有帮助。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与获得执照的咨询师匹配，并且可以随时更换
therapists any time for no additional charge. Find your bright spot this season with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash smartless. Hey smartless fans, have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show, Add Free, and one week early on Amazon Music with your prime membership? That's right, all your favorite smartless episodes can be heard, Add Free, anytime on Amazon Music,
咨询师，无需额外付费。在这个季节通过BetterHelp找到属于你的心灵亮点。今天就访问betterhelp.com/smartless，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是BetterHelpHELP.com/smartless。嘿，SmartLess的粉丝们，你们听说过吗？只要拥有亚马逊Prime会员资格，就可以在Amazon Music上无广告收听本节目的单集，而且还能提前一周收听！没错，你所有最喜欢的SmartLess节目都可以在Amazon Music上随时无广告收听，
and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all, you can listen to your other favorite shows like I don't know, Bad Dates and Just Jack and Will. Early and ad-free too. They also have favorites like The Daily Part and My Take and Up First. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcast
并且你总是能第一时间听到我们的新节目，这样你就可以在朋友面前炫耀了。但这还不是全部，你还可以提前且无广告地收听其他你喜欢的节目，比如《Bad Dates》和《Just Jack and Will》。它们还拥有诸如《The Daily Show》、《My Take》和《Up First》等热门节目。Amazon Music提供最多的无广告顶级播客，
so we know they definitely have something for you. And it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com-smartless. That's Amazon.com-smartless or download the Amazon Music app. It's just that easy. Smartless is brought to you in part by LiquidIV. So guys, everybody needs to hydrate, right? It's so important.
所以我们知道这里面绝对有适合你的内容。而且这些都已经包含在你的Prime会员资格中了。要立即收听，你只需访问Amazon.com/smartless。也就是Amazon.com/smartless，或者下载Amazon Music应用。就是这么简单。SmartLess的部分内容由LiquidIV赞助播出。所以伙计们，每个人都需要补充水分，对吧？这太重要了。
It's the worst thing to be dehydrated. It's not healthy. You have to hydrate all the time. I'm doing a show, as you all know. On have to hydrate all the time. I'm doing a show as you all know. On Broadway, I sweat like a pig when I'm on stage. And so I need to rehydrate. I need to get all my electrolytes so that I can continue to keep performing, right?
脱水是最糟糕的事情。这很不健康。你必须时刻补充水分。正如大家所知，我正在参演一档节目。在百老汇，我在舞台上表演时汗如雨下。所以我需要重新补水。我需要补充所有的电解质，这样我才能继续坚持演出，对吧？
It's just really, really important. Liquid IV, the number one powdered hydration brand in America, is now available in sugar free. Years in the making, hydration multiplier sugar-free uses a proprietary zero-sugar hydration solution with no artificial sweeteners, with three times the electrolytes of the leading sports drink, plus eight vitamins and nutrients
这真的是非常非常重要。Liquid IV，全美排名第一的粉末状补水品牌，现在推出了无糖版。历经多年研发，“补水倍增器无糖版”采用专有的零糖补水配方，不含人工甜味剂，电解质含量是领先运动饮料的三倍，外加八种维生素和营养成分，
for everyday wellness. Liquid IV hydrates two times faster than water alone. Keep your daily routine exciting with three new flavors, white peach, green grape, and lemon lime. I kind of like anything grape, so I really, really like the green grape one. Liquid IV believes that equitable access to clean and abundant water is the foundation of a healthier world.
助力日常健康。Liquid IV的补水速度是单纯饮用水的两倍。三种全新口味让你的日常充满惊喜：白桃、青提和柠檬青柠。我基本上喜欢任何葡萄味的，所以我真的非常非常喜欢青提味的。Liquid IV坚信，平等获取清洁且丰富的水资源是建设更健康世界的基石。
They partner with leading organizations to fund and foster innovative solutions that help communities protect both their water and their futures. Real people, real flavor, real hydrating, now sugar-free. Grab your liquid IV hydration multiplier sugar-free and bulk nationwide at Costco or get 20% off when you go to liquid IV.com and use code SmartLess at checkout. That's 20% off anything you order
他们与领先的组织合作，资助和推动创新解决方案，帮助社区保护水资源和未来。真实的人，真实的口味，真正的补水，现在推出无糖版。赶快在全国Costco大批量选购你的Liquid IV补水倍增器无糖版，或者访问liquidIV.com并在结账时使用代码SmartLess即可享受八折优惠。在liquid-IV.com
when you use promo code SmartLess at liquid-IV.com. All right, back to the show. I want to say two things. One of the things I like that you kind of talked about was in kind of getting into things and whether it's about work or in your personal relationship. I've just recently in the last week been talking with a friend of mine about this concept, this idea that when a relationship, if you will, between two people is strong enough that it can sustain each other, being able to feel free to do what they need to do and express themselves in a way that's okay. And when it can support that, there's something really magical about that.
使用优惠码SmartLess即可享受任何订单八折优惠。好了，言归正传。我想说两件事。我挺喜欢你刚才谈到的一点，就是关于如何深入融入某些事情，无论是工作还是个人关系。我最近在一周内刚好和一个朋友聊起这个概念，这个想法是：当两个人之间的关系（如果你愿意这么说的话）足够牢固，能够互相支撑时，双方就能感到自由去做他们需要做的事情，并以一种没问题的方式表达自我。当关系能够支持这一点时，就会产生一种非常神奇的东西。
When we can be comfortable enough to have differing opinions on things, because I think so often, I don't know, I don't know about you guys, but I've been in places before, in relationships where it wasn't strong enough, and so that when you do kind of strike out and have a differing opinion, it kind of falls apart. There's something really great about when it is strong.
当我们能够足够舒适地对事情持有不同意见时，因为我觉得通常情况下，我不知道，我不知道你们怎么想，但我以前也曾处在某些关系中，那时的关系还不够牢固，所以当你试图跳出常规持有不同意见时，关系就会分崩离析。而当关系足够牢固时，就会有一种非常棒的感觉。
In that way. Well, luckily politically, we're and that makes that makes dinner conversation much easier. We've been together a quarter of a century so we've worked out the King. I mean there's not a place where I mean I think with any you guys know this. I mean you've been a you know I'm a bit further down the Mathusel trail than you are, but by about 10 years, I think. But, but, um, you know, you, you, you, you, communication is everything. And if you can't, if you can't, if you don't have that, then you're just kind of screwed, you know.
就是那种感觉。好吧，庆幸的是我们在政治立场上是一致的，这让晚餐时的对话轻松多了。我们已经在一起四分之一个世纪了，所以我们已经把这些问题搞定了。我的意思是，总会有一些地方，我是说，你们任何人都懂这一点。我的意思是，你们经历过，你知道的，我在玛土撒拉（Methuselah）这条路上比你们稍微走远了一点，大概远了10年吧。但是，但是，嗯，你知道的，你，你，你，沟通就是一切。如果你不能，如果你不能，如果你没有那个，那你基本上就完蛋了，你知道的。
Yeah. Okay. Wait. Here, Michael, you like times and dates. I ran, I didn't run into you. I saw you once. It was a great, I was 24 and I was on 7th Avenue. None of it exists anymore, but I was on 7th Avenue in 20. I lived between 7th and 8th on 21st Street in Chelsea for years. Okay. And I saw you at this weird rush, and I'm like, what the fuck is Michael's type doing there?
是的。好吧。等等。听着，迈克尔，你喜欢时间和日期。我遇到过你，我不是偶遇你。我见过你一次。那是个很棒的经历，我当时24岁，在第七大道上。虽然现在那些都不存在了，但我在1994年时在第七大道上。我好几年都住在切尔西第21街第七大道和第八大道之间。好吧。我在这个奇怪的地方看到过你，当时我就想，迈克尔·斯泰普在这儿干什么操蛋的事呢？
And you were having coffee outside at this really, and anyway, it was a great sighting. And I remember just walking by, trying to be cool and going around the corner and saying to my friend, like, yeah, yeah. On 21st, I can't picture. You were on 7th Avenue. It was 1994.
你在外面一家非常……不管怎样，那是很棒的一次偶遇。我记得我只是走过去，假装很酷，然后拐过街角，对我的朋友说，对，对。在21街，我想象不出来。你在第七大道。那是1994年。
On 7th, okay. There's no way you remember it. But it was like for me, a great like, you know, just trying to, you know, those like, trying to walk cool and be like, is my walk look stupid? Am I walk? How do you walk?
在第七大道，好吧。你不可能记住了。但对我来说，那真是一次绝佳的经历，你知道的，就是试图装酷，心想，我走路的样子看起来很蠢吗？我走路的样子？你怎么走路的？
How do some walk do something walk normally? Just walk normally. Walk like a human person. Oh, that's weird. Oh, that's weird. Wait, so Michael, I have a question. How old were you when Murmer came out? 22, I think, or 21, 22.
正常人怎么走路？就正常走路。像个人类一样走路。哦，那好奇怪。哦，那好奇怪。等等，迈克尔，我有个问题。《Murmer》发行时你多大？我想是22岁，或者21、22岁。
22, which means you started writing. Like you said, you're 23. Wait, I think, yeah, no. I was born January 4th, 1960. So I'm every decade, I'm like four days behind. So I'm now 63. It's really hard to remember. So you were, I was 13, so you're 23.
22岁，也就是说你开始写作的时间。就像你说的，你23岁。等等，我想，是的，不对。我出生于1960年1月4日。所以我每一个十年都好像慢了四天。我现在63岁了。这真的很难记住。所以你当时，我当时13岁，所以你23岁。
I think it came out in, I think, yeah, 23. 23, yeah. Yeah, so you're 23. And meaning, like you said, you started writing in high school and when you were a teenager. And so my question is because I'm always fascinated by people like you who, how did you get in touch with your emotional side at such a young age such that you could feel fearless
我想它发行于，我想，是的，23岁。23岁，是的。是的，所以你当时23岁。也就是说，正如你所说，你从高中和青少年时期就开始写作了。所以我的问题是，因为我总是对像你这样的人感到着迷：你在那么年轻的时候是如何与自己感性的一面建立联系的，以至于在通过音乐表达自我时能感到无所畏惧？大多数青少年都有青春期的烦恼，本来就很情绪化，但要感到足够安全把它们写下来然后唱出来，则是完全不同的另一个层面。你是怎么做到这一点的？
about expressing yourself through music? Like most teenagers have angst in our naturally emotional anyway, but to feel safe enough to write them down and then sing is a whole other level. How did you achieve that? Wow, that's such a good question. Maybe unanswerable. I mean, well, I love what you said earlier, Will, about radio for Europe, because it was
哇，真是个好问题。也许是个无法回答的问题。我是说，好吧，Will，你刚才关于欧洲电台的说法我很喜欢，因为那是
you know, it was fear. I mean, there was everything was an ambition and audacity. There was, it was all the A words. I mean, there was everything was an ambition and audacity. There was, there was, it was, it was all the A words, except for F, which is the fear word. But we grew up in public, you know, we didn't know what we were doing. Peter couldn't play guitar. I didn't know.
你知道的，那是恐惧。我是说，一切都是野心和胆识。那是，全都是以A开头的词。我是说，一切都是野心和胆识，有，有，有，全都是A开头的词，除了F，也就是代表恐惧（Fear）的词。但我们是在公众视野中长大的，你知道的，我们当时根本不知道自己在做什么。Peter不会弹吉他。我不知道。
I didn't, it didn't occur to me that to be the singer in a band I had to write words and then sing them. Like, I mean, I was like, yeah, this is great. But it's, it's a lot of work. The Ramones emerged intact. They were like this remarkable thing that just the second you saw them or heard them, they had a sound, they had a look, they had names, they had an attitude, they had the, they had all the photography down, they were locked from the first moment we ever saw them. I am grew up in public and so it took me a couple of...
我，我当时并没有意识到，要成为一支乐队的主唱，我必须先写出词然后唱出来。我是说，我当时觉得，太棒了。但这其实需要付出很多努力。The Ramones（雷蒙斯乐队）一出现就保持着完整的状态。他们就像是一个卓越的存在，你一看到他们或听到他们，他们就有自己的声音，有自己的外表，有自己的名字，有自己的态度，他们把所有的摄影风格都拿捏得死死的，从我们第一次见到他们的那一刻起，他们就已经定型了。而我是伴随着公众的注视长大的，所以我花了好几……
I mean, people don't believe this, but I repeat it over and over again. We were working on our second album before I realized that the bass guitar was the one that made the low sounds. I didn't know the difference between a bass and a guitar. The bass has four strings on it, so that's what I wanted to know. That's how I knew that was the base. It had four strings. But you knew you could sing. No, I didn't.
我是说，人们可能不信，但我一遍又一遍地重复过。我们在制作第二张专辑时，我才意识到原来低音吉他（贝斯）才是发出低沉声音的那把吉他。我当时根本分不清贝斯和吉他。贝斯有四根弦，所以这就是我想知道的。我就是这样认出那是贝斯的。它有四根弦。但你知道你会唱歌。不，我不知道。
I only figured out, and like, what was the second to last record that we made? How did you find your way into a band? Well, how did you start the band? It was, is my right was Peter Bach? One of you was working at a record store? Was it Peter was? Yeah.
我直到，比如，我们制作的倒数第二张专辑时才弄明白这一点。你是怎么走入乐队的？好吧，你是怎么组建乐队的？是，是对的，Peter Buck？你们其中一个当时在唱片店工作？是Peter吗？是的。
He was working at record store and used to come in and buy Patty Smith records or something. You're never gonna believe this, but at that record, that record store is still there. It's in Athens, Georgia. And you'll never believe who's going to be there in early November. Who's that?
他在一家唱片店工作，以前经常去买Patti Smith的唱片什么的。你绝对不会相信，但那家唱片店现在还在。它在佐治亚州的雅典。你绝对不会相信今年11月初谁会去那里。是谁？
Mickey Dolan's from the monkey. Wow. No way. Has covered four REM songs and the last one on an EP. And they are fucking fantastic. And he covered one of the songs and we lost them on an EP. And they are fucking fantastic. And he covered one of the songs that we only wrote because it's called Shining Happy People. It's very fruity.
Monkees的Micky Dolenz。哇。不会吧。翻唱了四首REM的歌，最后一首在一张EP里。而且它们真是好听极了。他还翻唱了其中一首我们专门写给...叫《Shiny Happy People》的歌。这歌听起来很基。
I love that one. B-52's Kate. I love that song. With Kate Pearson, yeah. I love Kate. But you know, that was us working out our like, like, you know, like Super Pop kind of, I love it.
我很喜欢那首。B-52's的Kate。我很喜欢那歌。和Kate Pearson一起唱的，对。我很喜欢Kate。但你知道的，那是我们在创作那种，像超级流行乐那样的音乐，我超喜欢。
Bubble gum, kind of bubble gum music. It's because of it. Was that on green? Oh, God, you're asking the wrong person. I know. It was on one of those records around that. If we could find somebody in the band. I love how much you don't know your own.
泡泡糖音乐，那种泡泡糖音乐。正是因为这个。那是收录在《Green》里吗？哦，天哪，你问错人了。我知道。那是那期间的某一张唱片里的。如果我们能找到乐队里的某个人就好了。我太喜欢你对自己（的作品）一无所知的样子了。
He has what we call turn the page. It's fucking rad. I think it's so rad. And you know what else is rad? Is that you, you know, you mentioned the runs, how to look and everything. You guys, you, clear, had no runs, how to look and everything. You guys, you had no look, almost by choice.
他有所谓的“翻篇”能力。这太特么酷了。我觉得这酷毙了。你知道还有什么很酷吗？就是你，你知道的，你刚才提到了雷蒙斯乐队，他们的外形等等。你们，你们，尤其是你，几乎是有意为之的不刻意打扮。
It seemed very like, there's no artifice, no nothing. We're gonna plug these instruments in and we're just gonna sing and play music that sounds good and it's challenging, but it's not alienating. It's, especially, by the way,
看起来非常像，没有任何矫揉造作，什么都没有。我们只要把这些乐器插上电，然后只管唱歌，演奏听起来很棒、很有挑战性但又不会让人产生疏离感的音乐。尤其是，顺便说一句，
JB, think about this, especially in a time, Michael, you can attest to this, where MTV was exploding and a lot of music was about how your video played. It wasn't necessarily about your music. And you guys were all about the music. To me, music was, music was like one of the one places that you could go and not have someone tell you what to think about and not tell someone, Like when I hear music, this is also, I get a lot of stick for this, but it's really what happens. When I hear good music, not bad music. When I hear good music, I see a landscape and I see a vista. And for me, it's a very visual thing. And when I write, I'm like putting people in that landscape.
JB，想想看，尤其是在那个时代，迈克尔，你可以作证，当时MTV正在蓬勃发展，很多音乐都取决于你的MV拍得怎么样。它不一定取决于你的音乐。而你们全心全意只关注音乐。对我来说，音乐是，音乐就像是一个你可以去的地方，没有人会告诉你该对什么产生什么想法，也不会告诉你，就像当我听到音乐时，这也是我经常挨骂的原因，但这确实是我的真实感受。当我听到好音乐时，不是烂音乐。当我听到好音乐时，我眼前会浮现出一片风景，看到一片远景。对我来说，这是一个非常视觉化的事情。当我写作时，我感觉就像是把人们置身于那片风景之中。
It's like, it makes that makes sense to me. I see when I hear. So for MTV to come along, and suddenly you're looking at like, whoever, you know, Chrissy Hind and the pretenders version of what you're supposed to see when you hear this song, it really robbed me of something super important to as a music fan.
这对我来说说得通。当我听到时，我能看到。所以当MTV出现时，你突然看到，比如，无论那是谁，克里斯西·海恩（Chrissy Hynde）和The Pretenders版本的“当你听到这首歌时你本该看到的画面”，这真的剥夺了我作为一个乐迷非常重要的东西。
So what changed your mind? Washington, Ado Connor, it was when I saw nothing compares to you that I started lip-syncing. And the first video that I lip-synced to, lip-synced to, is losing my religion, which was the biggest hit that we had ever had. It was the song of the summer of whatever year that was. And I'm so proud of that song, and I love the song to this day,
那么是什么改变了你的想法？希尼德·奥康娜（Sinead O'Connor），当我看到《Nothing Compares 2 U》时，我开始尝试对口型。我第一个对口型的MV，对口型演唱的歌曲是《Losing My Religion》，这是我们有史以来最大的热门单曲。那是那个不知哪一年的夏天的热门金曲。我为那首歌感到无比骄傲，直到今天我依然热爱这首歌，
but it was watching her performance that I realized, like, okay, this is complete artifice, but we all know that it's artifice, and you can actually be moved emotionally by watching this person perform the song, even if she's up syncing. Who are your bands? I mean, who were, you mentioned the monkeys, et cetera,
但正是看了她的表演，我才意识到，好吧，这完全是人工造作，但我们都知道这是人工造作，而且你确实可以被这个人表演这首歌时的表现所感动，即使她在对口型。谁是你们的乐队？我是说，你们当时，你提到了Monkees等等，但当你，除了Patti Smith之外——你也提到了她——当你18岁或25岁时，有哪些乐队是你至今仍然……就像我有一个大概包含10支乐队的轮换清单，我总是会重温它们，其中REM就是其中之一，永远在我的播放列表里。哦，而且总是，就是你们，还有The Smiths，还有Pavement，
but like when you were, other than Patty Smith, who also mentioned when you were 18 or when you were 25, who are the bands that you still, like I have like a sort of like rotating list of like 10 bands that I always go back to of which REM is one, that's always on my playlist. Oh, and it's always, it's you guys, and it's the Smiths and it's pavement,
感觉那就是我精神栖息的地方。你们品味不错。是的。非常感谢。我是说，我不知道。我只是喜欢音乐。没有穿衬衫。我从来没。是的。当你在格莱美奖和MTV颁奖典礼等各种场合到处晃悠时，有哪些乐队是你当时真正感到兴奋能去跟他们打招呼的？说实话，我真正兴奋的是去跟演员们打招呼。
and it's like that's where I guys and it's the Smiths and it's pavement. And it's like, that's where I kind of live. You have good taste. Yeah. I'm well thank you. I mean, I don't know. I just like music. Not in the shirts. I've never. Yeah. Like when you were bopping around the Grammys and the MTV of awards and all that stuff, who, which bands at that time were you kind of really excited to be bumping shoulders with? I'll tell you the truth. I was really excited to be bumping shoulders with? I'll tell you the truth, I was really excited to be meeting the actors.
真的，在这方面我绝对是个狂热粉。所以比如我把丹尼斯·霍珀吓得魂飞魄散，我走过去，我不是故意的，我当时只是太兴奋了，肾上腺素飙升，而他就在那里。然后我就说，哦，你太棒了！我吓到了，我走到他身后，你知道的，他完全，就用那种眼神看着我，仿佛在说：弗兰克，哇，你太棒了。我吓到了，我走到他身后。然后他完全用那种看着弗兰克的眼神看着我。
I'm really, yeah, I'm a real fanboy in that regard. So like I scared the life out of Dennis Hopper, I went, and I didn't mean to, I was just so excited and so jacked on adrenaline and here there he was. And I was like, oh, you're amazing. And I scared, I came up behind him, you know, and he completely, like he looked at me with that look of like Frank, you wow, you're amazing. And I scared, I came up behind him. And he completely looked at me with that look of Frank.
你知道的，太吓人了。我当时想，啊，我把他吓到了。我把丹尼斯·霍珀吓到了。是的，他是个检察官。来自《蓝丝绒》的弗兰克。是的，他叫我检察官。他叫我检察官。我曾把埃尔顿·约翰视为，作为一个，
You know, it was so scary. I was like, ah, I scared it. I scared it to his hopper. Yeah, he was a prosecutor. Frank from Blue Velvet. Yeah, he called me a prosecutor. He called me a prosecutor. I loved Elton John as a, as like,
我当时就像个原生动物。你知道的，我，所以，就像我还是个原生动物的时候，你知道的，嗯，当《Bennie and the Jets》发行时我大概13岁，那首歌对我来说，我的感觉是：这特么到底是怎么回事？这是什么？就像我当时甚至连流行音乐或电台音乐的皮毛都不懂，但我当时就觉得，这是我从未听过的新东西。当我听到Patti Smith时也是这种感觉。
I was like a protozoa. You know, I, so, like, when I was like a protozoa, you know, um, I was maybe 13 when, um, Bidney and the Jets came out and that song to me, I was like, what the actual fuck is going on? What is it? Like, I couldn't, I knew even then, like, I didn't know the first thing about pop music or radio music or nothing, but I was like, this is something I've never heard before. And the same thing happened when I heard Patty Smith.
然后帕蒂，你知道的，嗯，我在70年代中期就知道纽约的CBGB以及在那里演出的所有乐队。所以当他们每人发一张唱片时，我都是排在第一个去买的人。所以Television、Ramones、Talking Heads、Blondie，还有Dead Boys，以及所有这些从洛杉矶崛起的人。
And then Patty, you know, uh, I knew about the CBGBC in New York in the mid 70s, and all the bands that were playing there. So when each of them released a record, I was the first guy in line to buy it. So television, the Ramones, the talking heads, blondie, and then the dead boys, and all these other people sort of coming X from Los Angeles
然后帕蒂，你知道，呃，我知道70年代中期纽约的CBGB俱乐部，以及所有在那里演出的乐队。所以当他们每一个人发行唱片时，我都是排队购买的第一人。所以，电视乐队、雷蒙斯合唱团、传声头像乐队、金发美女乐队，然后是死男孩乐队，以及所有其他这些从洛杉矶来的X乐队
because that we won't talk about. And I'm kidding. I don't despise LA. I just don't know who I am there. It's a real problem. We're gonna help you find yourself here. You're gonna come out here soon. I'm free on the ninth.
因为那个我们不会聊。我开玩笑的。我并不讨厌洛杉矶。我只是不知道我在那里是谁。这是个真正的问题。我们会帮你在这里找到自己。你很快就会来这边的。我9号有空。
So let's have to. We're gonna have Dennis. And this is, we're gonna change the way that you look at Los Angeles. First, you're about to meet the most dynamic people you've ever met. And they're all here on your screen. And they're all here on your screen.
所以不得不这样。我们要请来丹尼斯。这将是，我们将改变你看待洛杉矶的方式。首先，你将见到你见过的最具活力的人。他们都在你的屏幕上。他们都在你的屏幕上。
No. It's gonna be incredible for you, to meet us in person. It's gonna be so incredible, my God. What am I? To watch how little Jason eats and how much Sean eats, we'll blow you away, just cancel each other out.
不。亲自见到我们会对你意义非凡。太不可思议了，天哪。我算什么？看着杰森吃得那么少，肖恩吃得那么多，会让你大吃一惊，他们俩正好互相抵消了。
And we're both the same weight. I don't know how it works. It's true. What do you do? Because we always, what is the thing that you do that is, I don't know, the thing that you do. We'll be surprising to us. That's not why.
而且我们体重一样。我不知道这是怎么做到的。千真万确。你平时都做什么？因为我们总是，你做的那件，我不知道，那件你做的事情。会让我们感到惊讶。才不是因为那个。
That's not why. Yeah, yeah. To me, you are the embodiment of sophistication. What is the opposite of that? What? You're looking at it, buddy. Yeah. What are you talking to? I'm the least sophisticated person you know.
才不是因为那个。对，对。在我看来，你就是精致的化身。那它的反义词是什么？什么？你正看着呢，老兄。对。你在跟谁说话？我是你认识的最不精致的人。
You've ever met. But you're creating a lot of art. You've created art in so many different mediums now. And so for guys like us, I'm in awe of how you do that, and it's really inspirational, to be honest, hearing. This is not false humility, I really mean, I'm really... No, yeah, of course.
你见过的。但你创作了很多艺术。你现在已经在那么多不同的媒介中创作了艺术。所以对于我们这样的人来说，我对你是如何做到这一点的感到敬畏，说实话，听起来真的很受鼓舞。这不是虚假的谦虚，我是认真的，我真的是……不，对，当然。
It means so much to me. But I'm also saying it because... So what is the thing, like, as Jason said, that we'd be surprised to know that you do... That you... That you simple-ten might do, you know? I became a really good cook through COVID. I think we all did.
这对意义重大。但我也这么说是为了……那么有什么事，就像杰森说的，如果我们知道你做的事会感到惊讶……你会……你们这些普通人可能会做的事，你知道吗？我通过新冠疫情学会了做饭。我想我们大家都会。
I didn't bake bread. Good for you. I play solitaire a lot. Solitaire, there you go. There you go. There it is. But what about cooking? What's your go to?
我可没烤面包。真为你高兴。我经常玩纸牌。纸牌，这就对了。这就对了。就是这样。但做烹饪呢？你最拿手的是什么？
I'm vegan default. So most of what I make is vegan. But then I'll see a piece of turkey bacon and just shove it in my face. I'm not proud of that, but it does happen. I'll shove that in my face. Michael, I do want to ask you just really quickly, not because I just want a quick answer, but just because we haven't gotten to it yet, I don't want to take it any more of your time. But you, one of the great things that you're also known for throughout all this time, and you've used your music to advance a lot of causes and things that you believe in, and your activism is, start it was just such an early part of your trajectory as a person through the world.
我是默认的素食主义者。所以我做的多半是素食。但有时看到一块火鸡培根，我就会直接塞进嘴里。我对此并不引以为傲，但确实会发生。我会把它塞进嘴里。迈克尔，我真的很想问你一个问题，不是因为我只想得到一个快速的回答，而是因为我们还没聊到这，我不想占用你更多时间。但你，你在这么长时间里为人所知的伟大之处之一，就是你用音乐推动了许多事业和你信仰的事情，你的积极行动主义，从一开始就是你作为一个人在世界上轨迹的早期部分。
And has that continued? Imagine that's continued. And where is it taking you now? What are the things that your passion about in your activism? I try to encourage and support younger generations and the work that they're doing. I thought that my generation, which was, I'm really just,
而且这还在继续吗？想象一下这仍在继续。它现在把你带向了何方？在你的积极行动主义中，你最热衷的事情是什么？我试图鼓励和支持年轻一代以及他们正在做的事情。我曾认为我这一代人，也就是，我真的只是，
I think I'm about 10 years older than each of you. Yeah, you're exactly 10 years older. I really thought that my generation was going to be, you know, I took a course when I was in seventh grade, I believe. I remember the teacher was Miss Enoch, E-N-O-C-H. And the entire year's course was about environmental science. And it was about how, it was about pollutant and energy sources and how my generation was going to be the one to lift us out of this darkness and to move forward into this progressive future where, you know, we're not dependent on on on on oil or gasoline and and the air is clean and the oceans are, you know, the plastic situation that we have now never existed in whatever it was, 1971. And I really believe that. I mean, I'm that naive.
我想我比你们每个人大大约10岁。对，你正好大10岁。我真的以为我这一代会是，你知道的，我上七年级的时候上过一门课，我相信是的。我记得老师是埃诺奇女士，E-N-O-C-H。整整一年的课程都是关于环境科学的。它是关于污染物的，关于能源来源的，以及我们这一代人将如何成为引领我们走出黑暗、迈向进步未来的人，在这个未来里，你知道的，我们不依赖石油或汽油，空气是干净的，海洋是，你知道的，我们现在的塑料问题在1971年根本不存在，无论那是哪一年。我真的相信这一点。我是说，我就是这么天真。
But moving forward, there is that energy that youth has and audacity to actually pick something up and place it somewhere else. We find ourselves faced with much more than environmental disasters right at the top of the list, but there are so many things as Americans that we have, you know, I just think we're like, we have really shitty karma as a country. And that has to be addressed in some way. And we're seeing that happen in real life right now. I'm very concerned for
但展望未来，年轻人拥有那种能量和勇气，去真正拿起某样东西把它放到别的地方。我们发现自己面对的远不止环境灾难，虽然这排在榜首，但作为美国人，我们还有很多事情，你知道的，我只是觉得我们就像，我们作为一个国家有着非常糟糕的业障。这必须以某种方式得到解决。我们在现实生活中看到了这一点。我非常担心
the future, but that said, I'm an incredible optimist. And so yeah, there's, I mean, I don't know what, it's quite scatter shot, but I've been in the band and continue to be actually as a non, we're no longer together for about 11 years, but we continue to be a business, and we support and encourage as much progressive activism as we can. Think about it, man. I mean, we have, if there's one thing I want to say to this younger
未来，但话虽如此，我是一个彻头彻尾的乐观主义者。所以，是的，这里有，我的意思是，我不知道，这有点杂乱无章，但我曾加入乐队并至今仍在继续，其实作为一个非，我们已经解散大约11年了，但我们依然作为一个商业实体存在，我们尽可能地支持和鼓励进步主义的积极行动。想想看，老兄。我是说，我们有，如果要我对这个年轻的
new generation is, the only place you can start is a feather hits the ground before it's weight can leave the air. And when you can fucking understand that, we can solve fucking everything. Michael's type, we have absolutely monopolized your way too much of your time. Yeah, I think for out of time. Oh, very nice. Very nice. That's why I'm here. What an absolute honor and thrill to meet you.
新一代说一句话，你唯一的起点就是羽毛在落地之前它的重量就离开空气的那一刻。当你们他妈的能理解这一点时，我们他妈的就能解决一切问题。迈克尔，我们实在是太占用你的时间了。对，我想我们时间到了。哦，非常好。非常好。这就是我来的原因。能见到你绝对是莫大的荣幸和激动。
Huge honor. Again, just been such a fan of yours for so long, so much of your music. Right back. Played through various stages of my life. I can think of them vividly and how much you are. You are. You and your voice and your songs are part of my soul. Same here.
巨大的荣幸。再次强调，长久以来我一直是你的超级粉丝，你的很多音乐。彼此彼此。伴随着我人生的各个阶段。我可以清晰地回想起它们，以及你有多重要。你就是。你和你的声音还有你的歌声都是我灵魂的一部分。我也是。
Well, you guys kept me going along with Team America. I think you guys kept me going on the tour of us for tour after tour with my former band. So the gratitude is returned. Thank you very much. And thank you. I'm really pleased to have been here today. Yeah. gratitude is returned. Thank you very much. And thank you. I'm really pleased to have been here today. Yeah. Thank you very much. Thank you, Michael. We're going to see you for dinner. I'll see you for dinner. Yep. Yeah. Done. We're coming. All right. We're coming to get you. Thank you, Michael. All the best. Enjoy your day. Bye, bye.
好吧，你们和《美国战队》一起让我坚持了下来。我想你们在我前乐队的一次又一次巡演中支撑着我度过难关。所以这份感激我心领了。非常感谢。谢谢你们。我今天能来到这里真的很高兴。对。感激我心领了。非常感谢。谢谢你们。我今天能来到这里真的很高兴。对。非常感谢。谢谢你，迈克尔。我们晚餐见。我晚餐见你。好的。好的。说定了。我们要来了。好的。我们要来找你了。谢谢你，迈克尔。祝一切顺利。享受你的这一天。拜拜。
Bye. Well done, Willie. Thanks. That's so weird. I truly was. I was listening to an R&M song in the car yesterday of the day before and I was like, oh, perfect guest. Yeah, perfect guest. I just bought like three of his albums because I, just the other day on digital because I never had them. I've only had them vinyl. Oh, yeah, I, they are one of those bands for me, R&M, where I have owned them on vinyl and on cassette and on CD and on digital.
再见。干得好，威利。谢谢。太奇怪了。我真的。我昨天或前天在车里听了一首R&M的歌，我想，哦，完美的嘉宾。对，完美的嘉宾。我刚刚买了他大概三张专辑，因为我，就在前几天买的数字版，因为我以前没有。我只有黑胶唱片。哦，是的，我，对我来说他们就是那种乐队，R&M，我拥有他们的黑胶唱片、磁带、CD和数字版。
I've owned them in so many, every available format, because you want to keep, you know, listening to their music wherever you are, I just... Yeah, he's, I miss his brain, his creativity, you know, is the subversive sort of take on things through music and sound and lyric. Those are the kind of people that we need who being our pop stars. I mean, I guess your pop music is so big and vibrant right now and God bless them, but I feel like we're missing a little bit of a counterbalance there or maybe I just need to look at them.
我在太多，每一个可用的格式上都拥有它们，因为你想一直在，你知道的，无论你在哪都能听他们的音乐，我只是……是的，他，我怀念他的大脑，他的创造力，你知道的，那种通过音乐、声音和歌词对事物的颠覆性看法。我们需要这样的人来当我们的流行巨星。我是说，我猜你们的流行音乐现在如此宏大充满活力，上帝保佑他们，但我感觉我们在那方面缺少了一点制衡的力量，或者也许我只是需要关注他们。
No, I think you're right. I think that we need rock stars and musicians who are creating music that's, you know, that's so important who also have something to say who are, you know, that have some depth to it and have some meaning. And it's like all hands on deck right now to try to trigger a better thought. Yeah. Sean, you've yet any thoughts triggered you? He's just working on buys over there. He's probably not. I love him.
不，我想你是对的。我认为我们需要摇滚明星和音乐家来创作音乐，你知道的，那非常重要，他们也有话要说，你知道的，这其中有一定的深度和意义。现在就像是全员出动，试图引发更好的思考。对。肖恩，你有什么想法被触动了吗？他在那边正忙着买东西呢。他可能没有。我爱他。
I'm with by. He is. Read. Re-submit. No, I am. Hey, that was that. I would like all the all the music people you both bring on. It's so cool. Like it's. No, I, um, he that was that I like all the all the music people you both bring on. It's so cool.
我支持买。他是。重新提交。不，我是。嘿，就是这样。我希望你们两个请来的所有音乐界的人。太酷了。就像是。不，我，嗯，他那是那个我喜欢你们俩请来的所有音乐界的人。太酷了。
Like it's no, I don't have. He's going. He's going. I do. I think like I'm so surprised. You know, I fucking fell into my chair when the Peshmoe came on. I fell out of my chair when, uh, when Michael Stype just came out and all these people come on and well, I'm falling out of my chair with it.
就像是，不，我没有。他来了。他来了。我有。我觉得，我太惊讶了。你知道，当佩什莫（Peshmo）出现时，我他妈的从椅子上摔了下来。当，呃，当迈克尔·斯泰普刚出来时，我从椅子上摔了下来，所有这些人出现时，好吧，我真的从椅子上摔下来了。
It's it really is. I'm sitting there watching. I was like like I can't believe I'm talking. I know the podcast is such a gift. I know officially for the three of us. Listener, it's all your fault. Thank you so much for giving us an opportunity to sit here. And hopefully we're asking some of the questions that you would ask if you were trapped in an elevator with one of your heroes too, like we are for an hour each day. It's just such a gift that we could talk to these folks. I can tell we're for hours and forgive us sometimes because I know that people are like, oh, you know, you didn't, you guys didn't let them finish or you were fans as well.
这真的，我坐在那看着。我当时想，就像我简直不敢相信我在说话。我知道播客真是一份大礼。我知道对我们三个来说官方是这样的。听众朋友们，这全怪你们。非常感谢你们给我们这样一个机会坐在这里。希望我们提出了一些问题，如果你和一个英雄被困在电梯里，你也会想问的问题，就像我们每天一个小时所做的一样。能和这些人交谈真是一份大礼。我能看出我们聊了几个小时，请有时候原谅我们，因为我知道人们会觉得，哦，你知道的，你们没有，你们没有让他们把话说完，或者你们也是粉丝。
So we trip over ourselves. I know that I do. Sometimes I'm not as, we fight for the next question. Yeah, because I'm like, I just, we only have him for an hour and I just wanna tell him how great I think he is. And stuff and people are like, oh God, how annoying.
所以我们会语无伦次。我知道我是这样的。有时我没有那么，我们会争夺下一个问题。对，因为我想，我只是，我们只有一个小时的时间，我只想告诉他我觉得他有多棒。诸如此类，人们会觉得，哦天哪，真烦人。
I know that's how I, that's how I, I gotta tell him all this time. I ran into you. I sing the song. The blah blah blah blah. And this song means, I could go on and on about it. And we could go on and on with him,
我知道我就是这样，我就是这样，我得一直告诉他。我偶遇了你。我唱了这首歌。啦啦啦啦。这首歌意味着，我可以滔滔不绝地讲个没完。我们可以跟他滔滔不绝，
but because it's always so sad to say, oh, you're good. Bye. Bye. Well, let's harmonize like how the audio would, good. Bye. Bye.
但因为说出“哦，你很好，再见，再见”总是那么悲伤。好吧，让我们像音乐那样和谐地来一句，好，再见，再见。
Hey, we did it. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grandterry. [♪ INTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smart, blessed! Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music,
嘿，我们做到了。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。Smartless是由罗伯·阿姆朱夫（Rob Armjurf）、贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbaco）和迈克尔·格兰特里（Michael Grandterry）100%有机且手工打造的。[♪ 播放开场音乐 ♪][♪ Smart, blessed! ♪]我们的下一集将在四周后发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，
or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts, or the Wondri app. [♪ INTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Today, hip-hop dominates pop culture, but it wasn't always like that, or the Wondry app. Will Smith. This is Class of 88, my new podcast about the moments, albums, and artists that inspired a sonic revolution. And Secured 1988 is one of hip-hop's most important years. We'll talk to the people who were there. And most of all, we'll bring you some amazing stories.
或者通过在苹果播客或汪迪（Wondery）应用上订阅汪迪加（Wondry Plus）来提前收听无广告版。[♪ 播放开场音乐 ♪][♪ 今天，嘻哈音乐主导了流行文化，但情况并非一直如此，或者在汪迪应用上。威尔·史密斯。这是《88届》，我的新播客，讲述了激发声音革命的时刻、专辑和艺术家。确立于1988年是嘻哈音乐最重要的年份之一。我们将与亲历者交谈。最重要的是，我们将为你带来一些精彩的故事。
You know what my biggest memory from that tour is? It was your birthday. Yes, and you brought me to Shoday Life Size Hardware Cutout. This is Class of 88, the story of a year that changed hip hop. Listen to Class of 88 wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge the entire series right now on the Amazon Music App or Audible. right now on the Amazon Music app for Audible. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道我从那次巡演中得到的最大记忆是什么吗？是你的生日。是的，你给我带了一个肖代（Shoday）真人大小的硬件纸板立牌。这是《88届》，一个改变嘻哈音乐的年份的故事。在任何获取播客的地方收听《88届》。你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐应用或Audible上狂刷整个系列。现在就可以在亚马逊音乐应用或Audible上。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。